Minky!
Welcome back, master and miss!
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello.
Hi.
Welcome, everybody.
Oh my goodness.
I'm back!
What was I gonna say?
How's the coffee?
It's good!
It's very good.
Oh my gosh, I was feeling so fine today.
Then I have dinner and now I just feel so icky.
So I apologize.
I think I'll feel better eventually.
I like...
Are you eepy?
I'm a little eepy.
But...
I found out recently...
I found out recently that I...
I take some vitamin supplements.
And I...
I found out that that was what was making me sick.
So I...
That will only take half.
Yeah, the iron.
Yeah!
I didn't know that iron supplements... I would, like, take it...
And then I would, like, feel so nauseous.
I thought for some time I would have, like, food poisoning.
But I think it was...
It's because, like... I don't know.
There's something with...
Iron supplements that...
Can make you feel... I don't take a lot.
I don't take a lot.
I think it's just...
It's just something that a lot of people have...
With the iron supplements.
Oh my gosh.
So...
Yeah.
The little... I got some gummies.
Some iron supplements.
Gummies in Japan.
And...
It said take two a day.
I remember when I would...
I felt so horrible.
And I was like, why do I feel so bad?
Phantoms need iron?
Yeah, you know...
For, like, ectoplasms.
They teach it to you in school.
Well, probably not your schools.
You know.
I'm at Olive Garden.
What should I order?
What do they have at Olive Garden?
What do they have at Olive... Breadsticks?
Order some breadsticks.
Made Minky Mingo Wimpo.
I was wondering if you got any updates from Mitsukiyo-san about uploading the intro stand-alone so we can lose it.
Oh, lose it.
Loop it.
I'm ready to lose it.
He messaged me actually the other night about posting it on Twitter on his end.
I'll ask if I can also post it on YouTube as its own thing.
You guys like my opening BGM that much?
It's so good, isn't it?
Right?
Let's need iron in order to generate electromagnetic fields to scare Zach Bagans.
Happy Saturday Minto.
Happy Saturday!
Happy Saturday.
Such an earworm.
I know, right?
Oh my gosh, I'm so happy.
So happy I can work with Mitsukiyo.
I'm heading to Japan so I was wondering if you have any recommendations for what to eat out there.
Eat.
Moss Burger.
Eat Moss Burger Teriyaki Rice Bun Burger.
Some people will tell you that Moss Burger is mid.
But Moss Burger Teriyaki Rice Bun Burger is the greatest thing ever!
So good.
I don't know.
I've never had anything else on the menu except the Rice Bun Burger.
So honestly the rest of it might be mid.
I have no idea.
It's a great intro especially after our cries.
I like Moss.
I got that burger last night.
Let's go!
Let's go.
I'm literally about to go to Akiba.
Is there a place I have to go?
Everywhere.
Melon Books.
Melon Books is good.
It can be smelly in there sometimes.
I'll go in there and I'll be like...
Wow.
This is man smell.
It smells so bad in here.
They need like a... What's it called?
Like an air freshener that smells like melons, you know?
No, you're not late at all.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome back Minto.
I wasn't able to catch yesterday's stream, but I'm here now.
It's also my birthday!
Kita!
I thought I'd send my first super chat to celebrate.
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Kita Tomoe.
Happy birthday!
I have a bit of an update perhaps, maybe.
A potential update on potential merchandise.
Maybe...
Your wallets.
Be careful next week.
Maybe.
If all goes well.
Shipping might take a while, so I apologize in advance.
But maybe like a couple months, honestly.
But...
We shall see.
We're used to long ship times.
I feel so bad though.
Like I thought that was unfortunately the first thing I thought about too.
I was just like, well, I feel most people are used to long ship times at this point.
And then I was like, no!
That's such a bad way to think!
I'm sorry.
My wallet?
No!
I'm ready to be in debt now!
Gonna buy some Ayami books if I found one.
Waiting for a Minto one someday.
Yeah, check Melon...
The past couple of times I've been to Melon Books, I feel her books have been sold out.
Ayami Mama so popular.
But...
Minto and Melon Books.
That would be the dream.
But also Comiket is coming up, so...
We'll see.
Yeah.
Comiket is coming up.
Which I will be going to Comiket by the way.
So, that'll be interesting.
I prefer winter Comiket, but it's so cold.
Down!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Say hi to Ayami Mama for us.
Are you going to try and vlog it?
That is...
That is the...
The goal.
But...
I don't know.
It's kind of...
How does Comiket smell compared to Melon Books smell?
Comiket is not bad at all actually.
Comiket is way more organized than I think people realize.
Like, it's very, quite easy to actually get around.
And as long as you know what circles you're trying to hit up, it's actually not so bad.
Yeah, it's actually not so bad.
Comiket.
Yeah.
Yeah, sorry, I'm going to Japan again.
It's meant to be a short trip.
I have...
It's an important reason that I have to go, so...
I figured I would be there for maybe, I guess, Comiket as well, so...
Ahem.
Ah.
Minto Frequent Flyer.
I know.
New maid cafe opening?
More like...
Favorite thing is closing.
So, final time I'm able to see Favorite Thing.
Unfortunately.
So I was like...
I hate the time of year that it's at.
Yeah, I did a karaoke with Denpogumi Inc.
A couple months ago they announced their final...
They announced their disbandment, disbanding.
And so finally the final...
The final show is upon us.
In about a month.
So...
Yeah.
So I'm sorry.
I feel bad because I really have taken so many trips over there, but...
There's just some things that I'm like...
I've missed so many...
In the past I've missed so many...
Graduations and disbandments and everything like that.
So I...
I feel...
Very grateful that I can go.
And...
And see them one last time.
And maybe my Kamiyoshi will make an appearance since she retired in like 2018.
Maybe.
If Comiket can be well organized, clean and good hygiene from all attendees...
Maybe all of attendees is a bit of a stretch.
People going to anime conventions like Otakudan, Anime Expo, etc.
have no excuse.
Well, okay.
I'll be honest though.
I've never been to Comiket in the summer.
Only Comiket in the winter.
In the winter, obviously, it's probably gonna be less sweaty, smelly, right?
I've never been to Comiket in the summer, so...
I thought Henya was your Kamiyoshi.
No, the difference between VTuber Kamiyoshi and Idol Kamiyoshi.
Difference, difference.
But yeah.
So, I don't know.
It might be...
It might be that...
Because, A, Anime Expo is in the summer.
Otakudan is in the summer.
Probably also Comiket's smelly.
I've been thinking about cosplaying though.
I don't know what I would cosplay.
I kinda wanna cosplay Blue Archive.
But it might be...
It might be...
Cold.
Well, the one time I did cosplay at Comiket...
I cosplayed Kaguya Luna.
And my arms were actually...
Like, I thought the ectoplasm was just going to turn into ice.
Like, if I...
I was so cold.
I was absolutely freezing.
So...
I don't know.
And also, if you've never been...
Okay, so if you go to cosplay...
If you go to cosplay...
You have to get changed in a room full of people.
Cherrino cosplay.
Cherrino might work.
Or...
Maybe.
Maybe you can go for Dempa final.
I saw them at Japan Expo Thailand and it changed my life way.
Can you give me some Firefly merch at Winter Comiket Mint?
Get your own!
Spank, thanks for the 20 good words!
Yeah, Red Winter dress warmly.
Maybe.
I'll think about it.
Also, it's like a pain in the butt though.
To cosplay.
Takes up so much space in the suitcase, you know.
Try Eva.
Sorry,
I've been talking for so long.
We're here to play Astro Bot!
Astro Bot.
Today might be the last day I play Astro Bot.
I might try to get through the final...
Final universe that we have left.
And then I might just be like, you know...
Time for other games, right?
Thanks Astros!
We love the yap!
25... No, no.
Actually, we're at game progress 55%.
The 75% you see there is a level.
Just a single level.
Not a...
Not the game.
But I think the 55% is like all the trophies and...
There's of course some bots I didn't get.
Some worlds I didn't see.
But that's okay!
How much do you think there is left?
As far as time goes?
I'm not sure to be honest.
I'm already starting to feel better.
So I think I'll just kind of go for as long as I feel like.
Yeah!
Maybe I'll even go back and get some things.
Yeah, yeah.
Hi Pinto!
How are you today?
I'm good!
Astro Bot.
Yeah!
Audio is...
Yeah, we have this bird place.
The last one.
The Feather Cluster.
But before we do that...
Yeah, maybe we...
Maybe we grab some that we haven't finished yet.
See?
There's two little guys here.
Oh wait, those are the extra levels.
Okay, nevermind.
There's a puzzle piece here we're missing.
No snake on the title screen.
So sad.
These are the last ones.
Which, we have quite a few actually.
Look at that.
Wow.
And then...
The puzzle piece here.
Yeah, so...
Like I said, I'm not gonna 100% so if I don't get every single little bot, that's okay.
But here, I definitely wanna go get this portal.
I think it'll drive me crazy otherwise.
We're missing a puzzle piece and a portal!
We gotta get this!
Astro Bot turned out to be quite the extensive game.
Right!
Honestly!
It was so funny.
When I posted my waiting room earlier on Twitter.com...
I looked over and I saw Astro Bot was trending.
And I was like, what?
And I think it's because...
What's his name?
George Keeley.
What's his... George?
I think it's because he posted about the...
What's it called?
The Game Awards?
Jeff!
Jeff Keeley.
Posted about the Game Awards and was just like, oh, Game of the Year is...
Nominations will be announced soon and I think...
People are... A lot of people were like Astro Bot.
And I saw a bunch of places posting about Astro Bot too.
I saw Resident Evil and everything.
So many posting about Astro Bot.
I was like, what?
Should I buy this?
Oh, I don't have enough.
Alright guys, we're gonna do this on our own.
We got this.
Probably.
They just added the last DLC update.
Is that why?
Oh my gosh.
There's just so much in this game.
It's kind of awesome.
Kill that guy.
If you guys don't mind helping me a little bit though...
Maybe we can get the...
Puzzle piece and the...
Wait, how do I...
Go in there, but like...
Why won't you stick in there?
Yes, help.
Yes, help!
Please.
So we can get it.
Okay guys.
I'm gonna look around places that...
Maybe perhaps I could have missed it.
Yes, help.
We got you.
Oh my god.
That guy just snuck up on me.
The puzzle piece or the warp?
Both.
Both!
A-Akuran merch for me.
Wait, how did this work again?
Oh, that's right!
Froggy gloves.
I'm looking around the si...
Oh no, that's nothing.
I'm looking around the sides...
To see...
If there's any puzzle pieces or warps...
That might be around.
Oh my god.
Can I punch his back at him?
Oh no.
Wait a second.
Wow!
I don't even know if I noticed that before.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Punch.
No, turn this way bot.
There we go.
Hey, it's Minto.
It's me.
Sorry for no schedule this week.
I will have one, of course, for next week.
Since I've just gotten back, I was like...
Oh, I'm not sure what I will be doing.
But we will have one.
Rest assured.
Oh, there's lots of money.
This is a good way to get more money too.
Hmm.
Appreciate you guys always being so...
So patient with me.
Thank you guys.
Have I missed anything yet?
I don't think.
Oh, I did.
I missed that.
Had some tough competition.
Yeah, I honestly...
I think it might get nominated.
But even if it gets nominated, I don't...
I don't quite think it will win.
As much as I would want it to.
I just think, you know, I'm just like...
Make...
Bring back fun video games.
Bring back games that like Spark, Whimsy and Joy, you know.
Just a little bit.
Games that are just kind of...
Fun and, you know, silly.
This one is just so well made too.
Which is such a fun.
I've been having every time...
I've been having so much fun with it every time.
I miss silly games.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
It was...
I think it's like...
You might enjoy the new Zelda.
Yeah!
And then like...
The graphics in it.
Like everything just looks so good, you know.
It's just like...
It's like...
This is like peak game.
Hit torches?
These?
Oh.
Wait.
Nice.
Punch you over here.
Help me!
Thank you!
Wait, but about the last...
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
100% the game, definitely worth.
Even the stuff added after launch.
Oh, awesome!
Help get...
Yes, thank you!
But...
What about the other puzzle piece?
Yeah, can we get the other puzzle piece and come back, I wonder.
Oh, I need you over here.
You need to go twice.
Yeah, right now viewers are assuring the streamer Minto that everything is alright.
They are glad that he is taking care of himself.
Second puzzle piece...
Is...
Wait.
Basically do the level a second time.
I have to?
Second puzzle piece might be passed apart.
You can't return from truth.
He didn't help.
Minto found it on her own.
Minto voice changer.
This is what I really sound like, guys.
You accept me?
The voice changer has been removed.
Alright.
Nice.
At least the portal isn't very far in.
Grapple?
How do you know my name?
Secret...
Oh my gosh, it was so towards the beginning.
What?
Secret...
Some of these I haven't completed either.
Oh, I remember this one.
This one is so... This one is at the very end.
Because I really want to finish all the puzzle piece stuff.
That's one thing I do really want to finish.
Fan club?
Wow.
My mom's been really enjoying these streams with me.
Fun games are the best.
Thank you, Senpai.
Thanks to your mom.
Oh my gosh, wait.
That reminds me.
Thank you for saying your mom.
Someone before stream, I saw...
Someone said really...
Someone said that it was their mom's birthday.
Kelly!
Mom Kelly!
If you're here, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Mom Kelly.
Happy birthday!
I don't know if they're still here.
Or if they'll even hear that, but hopefully.
But should we go... Let's do the fan club real quick.
We can check out what it's like.
Mama Kelly.
Blow!
It's kind of...
Wow.
Here's your cut, boss.
What?
What did I get?
Hello?
I had to jump up.
That's so cute!
Oh no.
The bane of my existence, literally.
Oh my gosh.
That was close.
No!
I
kicked his butt.
I was thinking Astro Bot can't win Gimme the Year.
It's against Baldur's Gate.
Three tears to the camera.
Those are last year, right?
Silly, those are last year.
Oh my god, he's drowning!
Oh my god.
No,
like I said, I don't...
I mean...
I don't want to say anything is rigged.
But I'm just saying...
That if a company had a lot of money...
And were to pay for more people to vote for a game that had a bunch of IPs...
I'm just saying.
But I do genuinely think this is such a good game.
So...
But I'm saying.
I'm just, you know.
Oh,
fun.
Not fun.
Just saying.
I'm not saying anything.
I'm just saying.
You know what I mean?
I'm not saying anything.
I'm just saying.
Okay.
There are so many guys here.
Wow, it's beautiful.
Bellatro sweep.
I've never played Bellatro.
What is in here?
Is it... Is it like...
How do I say it?
Like...
Poker?
He went to his ass slap, baby!
Who is this?
Mudokon Liberator.
Don't pull his finger.
Who is this?
Roguelike Poker.
If only they had...
If only they had a blackjack...
Then you know I'd be all in, baby.
That's kind of my thing.
Oh!
It killed me.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah.
This is so cute.
I thought it was going to be way different than how...
Than how it is.
Wait, hold on.
Let's go up here.
Yeah.
I thought this was going to be way different.
Like I thought we were going to use the fans to fly and all that.
Oh, hello.
Thank you!
There's a puzzle piece.
How do I get over here?
Okay.
Laser jump?
You think I can make it?
Seeing you enjoy silly games and laughing warms my heart.
Ow!
I should have known.
I'm glad!
Yay!
That was so easy.
He didn't even try.
I don't think he even tried.
What is going on in there?
Oh no!
Okay.
This place looks so breezy.
I would like to visit.
I would like to visit this location.
I got you!
Where are you?
I got...
Do you like public transport in Japan?
Yeah, I don't mind it.
Actually, I like it quite a lot because I enjoy...
I don't enjoy driving and I like walking.
Mudokon Minion.
Always laughs at the same joke.
Oh, they are like the same little guy.
Okay.
Oh no!
Aha!
Kind of a genius slice.
Same species.
Oh gosh, this looks scary you guys.
Minto is streaming.
I knew I smelled something stinky.
This is the guy called Eggman.
Your name is literally Egg...
Oh my gosh.
When I was coming home, the person next to me was eating eggs on the plane.
Why?
Why would you eat eggs on the plane?
Oh gosh, it smelled so bad.
She like peeled a hard boiled egg.
I was like, no!
We made it.
I was so...
That's devious.
I know, right?
I was like...
Eggs?
We missed a puzzle piece you guys.
No!
Can I fall back down?
Oh, the world has disappeared around us.
No!
I missed a puzzle piece!
I didn't realize.
Got it.
That one just pissed me off.
It's okay.
Overall, it was fine.
It was a decent flight.
Secret.
This one is also missing a puzzle piece.
We can do more gacha.
We could do more gacha.
Look at how big my army is.
Look how many guys.
We have 226.
Just a single piece.
Crash site.
Thank you guys.
Everybody, return to your positions.
Excuse me.
I just launched.
Oh boy guys.
Oh boy.
I hope I get no bottles.
I thought it was Raiden at first.
We don't have...
Did we get Raiden?
His sword?
Foreigner's Katana.
Keeps the yokai at bay.
Did we ever get his...
Outfit?
Horned Protector Outfit.
An iconic look.
Is this Undertale?
No, we didn't, right?
Is this it?
No.
Inherited Uchigatana.
This family heirloom slays.
I'm already out of money?
I only did like three.
Yeah, I don't think we got Raiden's sword, right?
Where is that guy?
Where is that silly...
Silly, silly...
There he is.
He's so bored.
He's so bored he's hand boning.
Do something, Raiden.
Do something.
He's like, you go do something.
You go make some money.
Okay.
There we go.
Off we go.
Saucy Jack.
He only had 359 coins.
I forgot that it was 100 per...
I thought...I don't know.
It's okay.
We're gonna go make lots more money.
Ginny of the lab.
Oh my gosh, a Gin for real.
This one has a lot of guys, so...
Let's go.
Oh, nice.
We'll get it.
Okay.
I had a feeling it was gonna be like that.
I had a feeling.
Oh, no, no.
How do I boost again?
Boost!
What are you?
Oh, sorry.
You live here, my bud.
He's like, I'm just a guy.
Chill out.
Look how cute he is in his little aviators.
His little aviators...
Goggles and everything.
I don't wanna hurt you.
It's my plane now.
Oh my gosh.
This is so fun.
I love this game so much.
Monkey!
I'm the sultan.
Oh, I have no face.
Are they Gangnam Style?
No, okay.
We're good.
Oh, perfect.
They look so shocked.
Little monkey.
Nice.
Thank you.
This music is so hard.
So cute.
Oh wait, it's not even a real plane.
It's fake.
Can I get up on those, I wonder?
Oops.
Oopsie.
I forgot that those guys smash.
Squish.
Do I have to get my money back?
Yeah, I could do.
I gotta go over here.
This map looks very...
Usually the maps are pretty linear, but this one is all over the place.
You see this?
There's someone on every corner.
It's craziness.
Oh, I almost had it.
Okay, hold on.
I'll save you!
Palace and Bazaar.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Gotcha.
Gotcha!
He's not even the first guy we need to get.
Look how many guys there are.
There's just enemies everywhere!
And I see that puzzle piece up there.
Can I ride this?
I tried to jump.
What about the clothes?
There we go.
There's also like a thing on top of that.
There's so much going on here.
What is this first?
Oh no!
I heard Minto does a sound that a concerned person would love.
Can I hear it again?
I do a sound?
What are those poop bots?
They attach to you because they're stinky.
Sometimes you're rewarded.
Rewarded.
I see him up there.
Let's go over here.
Let's check out...
There's so many!
He's doing it!
What's my sound?
I don't even know what sound I make.
Don't even try buddy.
Who are you?
Galactic Pirate.
Seeker of the Seven Star Sword.
Character is from Rogue Galaxy.
I see.
Look how many things are going on in here.
It's craziness.
Absolutely.
I'm rewarded for exploration.
So fun.
Be careful.
Be careful little guy.
Yay!
Finding the Steak Astro Bot.
So...
What's concerning about that?
There we go.
What?
No one's concerned.
No one's concerned, right guys?
Oh no, poor elephant.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Oh my goodness.
Let's just stand here.
This is totally normal.
Oh, sorry.
What's this?
Why?
How dare you come to my chat and say that?
I want that sound as my ringtone.
I can't just make a sound, you know?
I have to make it out of pure passion.
It's not just something... It's something that comes from the heart, you know?
It's not just something that I can be like, yeah, I'll make that sound for you.
No, I gotta... I gotta experience it, you know?
I gotta feel it.
Concern would imply it was an entirely predictable mental behavior.
Death to these guys!
Raw mental emotion.
Exactly!
Monkey!
Minky!
I slide right back down.
That scared the heck out of me.
Oh my gosh.
Is there anything around here?
So if you try to escape the world...
First of all...
OK.
Yes, I eventually can... I was gonna say...
How far can I go?
Not quite far actually.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you acting like a fool?
The way you say Minky makes it ten times funnier?
Minky!
It's like my favorite thing to say right now.
I'm so sorry.
It's just something about it.
Let's kill this guy too.
And take his money.
Oh shoot, we were so close.
Dumb Minky.
Oh
my god!
I just killed that guy!
How
can I not make it?
Maybe I need to go from this building instead.
Oh, I think...
OK, hold on.
We have to go a little bit ways of a roundabout way.
We have to take the clothesline.
We have to be a little pervert about it.
There we go.
OK.
Now watch.
Watch, watch.
The purple leaves?
I don't think you can jump on them.
I think we gotta go...
I was so close.
OK, here we go.
I think we go from...
Yeah!
Nice.
What is this?
Hell yeah!
I mean, I'll try from the purple leaves, but I really don't think it was...
Yeah, see?
Yeah, I can't.
I had that idea too though, earlier.
What's going on over here, huh?
What's going on over here?
Oh, I guess I could have used this.
Oh, it's OK.
I have an idea.
Maybe Minky in the donation pool?
Oh my gosh, what picture would we have for Minky?
Wait!
I could do that one of me doing the silly kick.
Come on!
Oh my God.
Yeah!
Nice.
Wait.
Before we go... Oh, sorry!
Oh, I'm so sorry!
I didn't... I thought there was... I'm sorry!
Here, I'll clean it up.
I'll clean it up.
I'll clean it up for you.
Into the bucket.
Everything in the bucket.
I'll clean it up.
He looks so traumatized.
No!
I'm sorry!
He's like... He's literally the cabbage guy from Avatar.
My bolts!
My nuts!
My nuts and bolts!
Wow!
Oh my God, it's crazy!
At what level does Minky evolve into Primmick?
Never.
Minky is a one evolution.
The only evolution you ever need.
Destroy!
There's gotta be money in here.
Big cash dollars.
See?
I told you.
That was so evil.
And big cash dollars!
Money.
There, see?
It pays to destroy.
This is all learned from Legend of Zelda.
I won't be able to watch stream today, but I just want to say goodbye Johnny's Combat.
It was nice seeing you.
I'm gonna miss that cute little war cry.
Hi chat.
Hi Minto.
Hello!
You think I got everything so far?
Let's see.
Ok, maybe.
This first area was humongous.
Oh my God.
Blizzard of Oz real.
What's happening?
Oh my God!
Minky!
Wait, you're not a real Minky.
That's not one of our guys, guys.
That's not one of our guys.
We don't need to...
No three wishes?
This is a genie.
It's a djinn.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is that...
Is that Nier?
No.
Who is this?
Cat from Gravity Rush.
Minky.
We're all fighting for our lives up here.
Can you just leave me alone while we're all fighting for our lives?
Cat from Gravity Rush.
You have a costume.
That's right!
Ok, I gotta be careful here.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
Evil, evil.
Having a guy there.
I got you!
Hold on!
I'll slap you off!
Gravity shifter.
If she's not in a rush, she's in a daze.
Oh my gosh.
This area is scary.
Oh my God.
Wait, which way am I going?
Oh, towards this guy.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, I couldn't see it.
I lost a coin, but...
Guys, we're just gonna have to...
It's fine.
It's one coin.
Why are there so many guys up here?
Don't get greedy.
I know, I know.
This one's gonna be really tricky.
Oh my God.
He killed off most of them.
That's so nice.
What is a dog... Oh, I think he like smashes.
Like he kind of like goes... Like that.
Nice.
Good thing we just got the...
Oh my goodness.
We got him?
We're okay?
We're still one puzzle piece and one portal and then three guys missing.
We still have a lot left, so I imagine...
I was kind of excited for the...
The what's it called?
The palace.
I thought we'd be able to go on.
A little disappointed.
I feel like the puzzle piece is like gonna be flying in the air somewhere, you know?
Oh wow.
Okay, hold on.
From here... I think I doggie dash over...
Okay, nice.
Excuse me.
Minecraft.
Minecraft bunny.
How did he recover?
Maybe I don't...
Don't...
Maybe I just leave him alone.
He's like a mini boss.
No, no, I don't leave him alone.
Stupid dog.
You made me look bad.
Oh my god, poopies.
No, poop!
No, more poop!
Oh, sorry.
We got him.
We got him, don't worry.
This poor snake is holding on.
He's got no hands.
He's got to use his little mouth.
Can we rescue the snake too?
This is so sad.
Oh my god, this poor snake.
Oh no.
I want to rescue him.
Take my hand.
It's so sad.
This guy is like, don't beat me up.
Beat me up.
You're pretty good.
Should have been a lizard instead.
How can he got no hands with his...
I don't know.
I don't remember how to defeat this guy.
Oh, just kidding.
That was close.
Dash.
We dash.
We're dashing.
We got Dasher and Dashing.
Gizmo and Blooping.
Nice.
Come here.
Oh my god.
Skewer!
Thanks for the membership, Danko.
Welcome, welcome.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Look
at this guy.
How am I supposed to kill him?
He can't even handle himself.
Minkies!
Hold on tight, Minkies!
My friend!
Wait, how do I...
Too heavy for the leaves.
Minkies, send me up.
Boost the tree.
How did I live?
How did I...
Maybe
I have to go from these blocks.
Just kidding.
Nice.
I know that's what I'm about to do.
Oh my god.
Nice.
First try, baby.
Somehow we didn't die.
Let's wait until the next rotation.
Guys, we died.
Poor guys.
Bad...
I have to go so fast.
As soon as it happens.
Nice.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe don't go in here.
Kill him.
Kill him again.
Don't fall off this time.
Where do I go?
Like a bo...
This Fall Guys update is wild.
Nice save.
Holy cow.
The dog is so dangerous.
Is that the last puzzle piece?
That was the last puzzle piece we needed.
It was just so randomly in there.
It was so random.
I feel like...
I knew it.
I was like, I feel like either a portal is gonna be around here...
Or something.
I got you.
Raven from Gravity Rush.
Yeah!
Defender of Hexaville.
Seems cold, but they'll crow on you.
Okay, nice.
But the portal...
What is it?
In like that little thing right there or something?
I have no idea.
Are these gonna turn around?
No?
Do I deflect this at you?
Yep.
Okay.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
Ouchie ouchie ouchie.
Okay.
Holy moly.
Meet the defender of the otaku.
Come here.
Oh, not these guys though.
These guys I avoid.
Then this guy I...
That was close.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't ever have enough...
I don't have enough...
Jumping me.
Okay, nice, nice.
Not these guys.
I can't... Oh, the wind is like making it more difficult.
Ah...
The wind makes it harder for...
Makes it harder for me to stay up I think is what...
Cause I'm like trying to move around, but I'm very slow.
I think it's the wind.
Okay.
Might not wanna boost sideways.
I think that's actually it.
Okay.
Play!
These freaking guys.
Oh gosh.
Ah!
Oh, I wonder if I can get them.
Maybe I just run around and then they'll destroy them for me.
You know?
Oh my gosh.
Maybe they'll destroy them for me.
I'm just gonna ignore them.
Oh...
Alright, ignore, ignore, ignore.
Unless I have to interact.
I ignore unless I have to interact.
Oh gosh, I have to interact!
Can you only get hit once?
Yeah, usually with the boss fights they give you multiple lives.
I'm so surprised.
That they only have... That it's only one life with these.
I'm kind of shocked right now.
Minky!
Oh my gosh.
Have you done any of the challenge levels?
Of course I have.
And I've completed every single one that I want to.
It's not the planet boss.
What?
But he has an introduction.
Minky!
Maybe I dog through them.
Oh my god!
I thought I got them both.
This is so... Oh my god.
This is the most I have had struggled on a boss in this game.
It's not just... It's like all the wins too.
That makes it tricky for me.
There we go.
Okay.
Please.
Minky!
Ignore, ignore, ignore, ignore, ignore.
Can I dash into the electric eyes or will I die there?
You can dog dash to... Oh, to dodge them.
Yeah, the purple guy killed some of them.
No, not into the electric.
Okay.
But I have to dash to get away from them.
Don't like the dash.
Minky!
I just can't jump in mid-air at all.
I can't jump in mid-air at all.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I missed the boat.
I'm sick of this song.
Do
it, Nankuu!
I have to eventually.
Well, I killed one.
Minky!
Please!
Go away!
You're scaring me!
Oh my god.
Minky!
Let's rob the rest of this place.
Oh, what the?
I don't think that's supposed to be like that.
Wait.
Is that how I get to the warp?
Is that how we get to the warp?
First try, boys!
How
do we figure out what the path is though?
Turn around!
Minky!
We did it!
First try!
I can show you the world.
Or a new world.
I can show... Wait, it is a whole new world actually.
Rocket.
High suction hero.
Hero.
I mean, I have to.
I mean...
I'll take it.
Give me my...
Oh, they're coming for me.
Oh gosh, they're coming for me.
Where are they?
Peggy!
What's the elephant do again?
Does it suck the water?
Or is this the one that inflates us?
I can't remember.
Oh my gosh, we have concrete.
Oh, interesting.
OK, OK.
Grab!
A whole new Minto.
A new rage to see.
No matter where you go, a whole new Minto to see.
I don't like these lyrics at all!
There we go.
Can I take the...
Ksss, ksss, ksss, ksss, ksss...
Ksss, ksss...
You can make up the three platforms.
Oh, really?
OK, nice.
Alright.
Where are you guys coming from?
Oh, that's right, he's sending them.
I
have to get more money first.
I got you!
Take my hand!
Thank you boss.
I got you.
I would never leave one behind.
Little birds.
I think I messed up.
I think I messed up, guys.
Was there something inside the cave?
I don't think there was, but I can check since I'm gonna be all the way back down here.
Doesn't seem to be the case.
We can get really close in person, although.
Kinda fun.
Lift!
OK!
Wait.
Take me up!
This one's fun.
This one's a little silly.
Because it's hard sometimes for me to...
Big coin.
For me to...
No!
Send me back!
I'm sorry!
Please.
No!
It's right there!
Should I restart?
The save is so evil.
I know!
What
the hell is that?
Wannabe Psycho Mantis over here.
I don't have anymore left.
I'm empty.
That's OK.
I think I'll just...
What the?
Excuse you.
Yeah, excuse you.
What is this?
Who is that?
The Glorp.
That's his name?
Is the Glorp?
Hold on, Glorp.
I gotta get some money first.
Glorp!
Militant Mutant!
Helghan, red eye catches you.
Don't freeze me.
What's this?
Oopsie.
I'll just wait for it to... There we go.
OK.
This way.
No, no, no!
Oh!
Holy moly!
Glorp Snake.
Is that his real name?
I'm confused.
How does this work?
How the hell does this work?
I
don't think I have enough.
I don't.
I'm out!
Sayonara!
Oh, come on!
Give me the big one.
Oh, that was close.
Wait, so does the cube give me Glorp?
Does the cube give me eyes?
No, I can't stop saying Glorp.
Thanks guys.
So the cube...
OK.
Alright, look this way little guy.
There you go.
Yeah!
I'm just worried that I'm not gonna have enough... What?
I have to choose?
Choose your fighter.
Oh my god!
There is the other puzzle piece!
I'm worried I'm not gonna have enough puzzle pieces to complete the thing, you know.
What is it?
I can't tell what the lyrics are saying.
SSP?
Oh, I'm an idiot.
Oh, SSD!
SSD...
You have to get every puzzle piece in the game to complete it?
Oh...
What is it?
I wonder what it makes.
Kill him!
Nice.
OK.
Collect my money.
No chance.
Oh, welcome to membership.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
How the heck am I supposed to get that puzzle piece without actually killing myself?
Oh, maybe with the stone.
I hear something beeping, but maybe it's whatever the thing I'm on.
Oh, there is a guy over there!
Yo, this game...
What?
There is a guy right there.
No!
Oh, I totally mistimed that.
Glorp.
I can't tell which one I should go for first.
Alrighty, alrighty, alrighty.
Oh wait.
I got it!
Nice.
Oh my god, oh my god, why did you jump like that when I...
Oh,
I messed up.
Oh shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Guys...guys...guys, if I just fall...
Nice!
Why do you move every time I do that?
Please don't do that.
Your leg almost falls off the ledge every time.
OK, OK, OK.
We did it!
Independent mutant.
We are all individuals.
OK.
Alright.
OK, we gotta...
This feels like a challenge level almost.
Just came back from my birthday dinner.
Wow, litter!
Hope you're having a fun time playing the game.
It's like PlayStation version of Super Mario Galaxy.
Yeah, it is.
I am having fun.
Happy birthday!
It's all the spinning.
I know, it makes it so tricky.
Holy moly.
Oh, we're almost there.
To the rocket ship.
Oh my god.
Why do you have to...
Why do you have to do that?
OK, OK, OK.
Are the coins within the blocks?
Yes, but I don't wanna waste...
Well, maybe I should.
Oh, I wanna get that coin.
What if I need it?
You know?
Don't fall off.
OK,
nice.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Slurp, slurp, slurp!
Slurp!
OK.
We did it guys!
Oh hi!
Hi!
You would have died in there.
You're welcome.
OK.
Oh, I think we have a real problem here.
Why are there so many cows?
Why are there so many cows and aliens?
What's going on?
Are they OK?
Destroy.
Take money, take my money.
Take my money, take my money.
Up here.
I'll take that.
And slurp it up.
Very good.
Come on guys!
Confused mutant.
Which one am I again?
Poor guy.
Slurp.
All of them, baby.
Full 100% of the planet.
OK, next one.
No, not next one.
Next one.
No, not the next one.
Oh my gosh, I never want to go back there again.
I never want to go back there again.
I forgot that I...
I did it 100%.
I forgot that I missed that one piece.
Oh, I thought you were being ironic.
Should we go get it?
You know what?
I never want to come back here.
We are going to get it, the one piece.
And we are going to leave.
We are going to get the one piece and we are going to leave.
We got this.
Easy guys, we got this.
The one piece!
Just came back from the zoo and saw a bunch of cape penguins.
The jackass penguin.
Jackass penguin.
Wow, oh my gosh.
Look how beautiful it is.
Can we take a second to appreciate the scenery here?
So beautiful.
And you know what?
I'm getting more money, so...
I guess it's not all bad, right?
It's good to get more money.
Oh shoot.
We got him.
Not that money.
Ignore that money.
Too much effort money.
Some money is worth too much effort.
Some money is too much effort.
We are speed running.
A little bit.
Kind of.
I need more of this.
Is this going to work?
Yeah.
Nice.
And they grab more.
OK.
Here we go.
Money.
OK.
Big money.
OK guys.
Yeah!
Leave planet.
Easy.
Nice.
There we go.
Secret.
Let's go back to the bird.
Back into the bird and then we'll...
What's that sound?
Him?
Is he going...
Frozen meal.
Oh my gosh.
I used to love those though.
Luna Sola.
Oh.
Lots to collect.
There is a lot to...
There is a lot to collect.
Absolutely.
The X challenge.
Lost Cross Void.
Later maybe.
X X Formerly Twitter or something.
Let's go to Frozen meal.
We are going to get so much money so we can do lots and lots of gacha.
But I don't want to like... Part of me is like I don't want to...
I want to... I'm running into everything.
I'm OK.
Is I want to be able to... I don't want to like...
Oh my gosh.
I thought we were landing there.
I want to be able to use any skins that I get.
You know what I mean?
Oh my gosh.
This is perfect for Christmas.
Oh no.
My money.
Surely these guys are kind.
They are kind.
Look at him.
Look at the way he is mean mugging me.
Turn around me.
Don't wait.
Why?
What am I turning around for?
Oh.
Ouchie ouch.
Those eyes aren't too kind.
No.
Little bunnies.
The bunnies give me money if I kill them.
Guys,
I feel like I'm throwing.
I gotta lock in.
How do I use this thing again?
Oh, there we go.
Gifted soul.
Has a not so imaginary friend.
Give me more money little bunnies.
The bunnies are filled with money.
Oh yeah, you too little bunny.
Give me more money little bunny.
Look, you can even knock the snow off of here.
Gosh.
So much in this little game.
David Cage game.
Why is it so fast?
What's that?
Oh, that guy.
OK.
Nice.
My cat is so entertained by your gameplay.
Really?
Nice.
I'll help you.
I helped him and he gave me money.
Oh my gosh.
Everybody help people.
They might give you tips.
You know?
If you help people, they might give you tips.
Here we... Oh god.
I should have expected that to happen.
I'm good.
Alright.
And...
Onwards!
Oh, he kissed me.
That was close.
Nice.
We call that a job.
Hit the trees.
Nice.
You guys, for the first time I heard that song from the Lorax.
How bad can I be?
I heard that.
I don't... I've never seen that movie.
The Lorax.
How bad can I be?
It's a fun song.
It actually is.
What's this?
I got this.
Oh no, I don't got this.
Makes me feel like I should watch the Lorax sometime.
I don't know.
How bad can I be?
All I said was skibbity.
How bad... Sorry.
Sorry, it has money.
Sorry.
Maybe next time you make a snow penguin, like, don't put money inside.
People won't destroy it, you know.
Look how we got some moves.
Watched a bit of it on BR chat.
What?
How?
All of these have such like crazy moving parts now.
Oh my god, no!
I missed a tree?
I did?
I don't think I did.
But I'll get all of them anyway.
There we go.
See?
I got all of them.
This still counts, right?
I could do it for the money, but I don't feel like it.
I will destroy this penguin's happiness, though, for the money, though.
I'll do that.
Okay.
Alright.
This one's a little tricky.
Wait, I missed a puzzle piece near the start?
Oh, I can't go back.
Why didn't you say it at the start?
I think that would've been easier.
It's better for me to know.
Oh yeah, I did miss one.
Oh, we did?
Oh, I didn't see...
You guys, I'm playing the game!
I'm not reading chat!
I guess I could maybe restart now.
This seems like a piece of doo-doo to get through.
Oh, what the...
Oh, it destroyed.
I got this.
Hmm...
Yeah, spunky fetus.
Should I just restart?
It's the very beginning, you can re-enter and leave?
Oh, okay, then we'll do that.
Oh my god.
Banana!
BANANA!
You need to do the level twice to 100% anyway?
Oh, okay.
Good to know.
No!
This is evil!
Leave me alone!
I got him.
Stress.
Stress, stress, stress, stress, stress.
I've never felt so much stress.
Yeah!
Kill the people.
Good job.
Thank you!
Oh...
Dummies.
I threw it though.
What the heck?
Double chunk chocolate...chocolate cookie.
No, don't, don't, don't, don't come after me!
Aren't you supposed to get tired or something?
Where'd the other guy go?
AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED TO GET TIRED?
Oh god.
Ouch, ouch.
I tried...
Do I have to laser him while he's crazy active like that?
The other guy fell off the edge, which is pretty funny.
Oh, see?
Like I have to...
I think I couldn't do it because I didn't have both guys.
That's kind of right.
That's kind of crazy.
OK, throw!
Nice.
It's a little awkward.
One second!
Don't freeze me.
Alright.
The lasers work.
They do.
Let's eat all of this snow.
What's this one do?
Oh, it gives me money.
I'll take it.
Can I explodey this guy?
That was so close!
I thought I wasn't gonna hit him!
We can.
Yummy snow.
It looks so fresh and fluffy, doesn't it?
It makes me want ice cream so bad.
It looks so fresh and fluffy snow.
OK.
I see.
Run, run, run, run, run!
Nice.
No way, is that...
Is that...what's his name from Robot?
Is that...what's his name from the Robot game?
Detroit?
Yeah!
Oh god.
How am I gonna get this money?
Connor!
How do I get to you, Connor?
Connor...
28 stab wounds.
Connor, how do I get to you?
Cut the ice around him.
Oh, maybe that'll work.
I'm just gonna...at this point I'm cutting everything.
Oh, maybe over here.
Can I redo?
How is it still standing?
You're making it hard...I'm not trying to!
It's OK.
Oh, it gives us...we just start from right here.
I think.
I think it's alright.
It was like the tiniest piece ever.
Oh my god.
Come here, Connor.
Oh my god, it really is him!
Deviant Hunter, the droid that droids dread.
28 stab wounds!
Why couldn't they reference that?
That would be so funny.
Oh, bird.
He's taking me out.
In a good way.
Oh my god, Mr...I was gonna say Mr. Krabs, but his name is Hank.
Mr. Hank might be in here.
Mr. Krabs.
I'm not wrong though.
OK.
Oh, oh.
Timed.
Oh shoot.
OK.
Yeah!
Oh my goodness.
OK.
28 stab wounds!
What the hell are those?
Wait, these are the things that were over there.
I don't know how to defeat these.
Oh my god, please.
Let me hit and destroy!
My reflexes are sometimes on point, you guys.
Oh no, I have to go back.
Alright, we gotta get him up there.
Can't you come down here, please?
How do I use this?
Oh, there we go.
That was close.
Hey!
Put your slack in!
He's fishing.
How do I kill these things?
Oh my god, he's staring at me.
Let him do that and then run up and...
Oh yeah, we did it.
Alright, here...
I can't jump.
I just have to punch him.
Yeah, just like that.
Nice.
What is this?
OK.
Nice.
I feel like I'm... I mean... I feel like I've already missed another piece, you know?
Wait.
Oh my gosh, I gotta get a picture with the snowman.
Oh, you're in love with me now, you freak!
What is this?
You're in love with me now, you freak!
Oh, I didn't mean to take the picture.
L2.
There we go.
Now he hates me.
I still feel like I'm missing something, you know?
Hmm.
Thanks for always being so cute and comforting.
Thanks, Maika!
Thanks for six months!
That was so close.
Oh my gosh, I see the puzzle piece.
Nevermind.
I see it.
I see it, I see it, I see it.
Jack Frost?
More like Jack Freak.
That guy's a freak!
But we got the puzzle piece, so...
All good in my mind!
I could get more money.
Pick!
And... Yes.
Yes!
These guys sound so funny.
They're like...
Nice dodge.
Thank you!
We still haven't found the warp.
The music up here is really nice.
Do I kick it through here?
Oh, up here.
Wait.
Wait, is it getting bigger?
Am I crazy?
Am I crazy or is it getting bigger?
Excited for the concert?
Thank you!
Thanks, Aikai!
It is getting bigger, right?
Then I can hop on top of it, right?
I have to go all the way here to get the secret.
Hmm...
The sock.
Because we still have to take care of this guy.
I have to get all the way back here.
People are saying you have to... Yeah, someone mentioned it earlier too.
It's just a matter of what I want to do first.
You know what?
We'll come back because we have to for the...
We have to for the puzzle piece anyway.
Choose number 3, my lord!
Lost Galaxy!
Is this the last one?
Is this the last Lost Galaxy?
Last Warp?
Did I find all of them?
Mushkash day complete?
What's this one?
Turtles in Trash?
That's so sad!
Why did I don't want to go there?
Don't you want to go to the trash ridden world where turtles and sea creatures are dying?
Isn't that the most fun level ever you ever thought of?
That's so sad!
Oh, you look sad.
Oh yeah, see there was the last little guy.
Alright, let's do it.
So, where is said puzzle piece?
Nice!
There?
Where?
Snowman at the ramp.
This guy up here?
No way it was that easy.
Diabolical.
Absolutely diabolical.
What is this?
Oh, oops.
This game is craziness!
I'm going to speedrun it a little bit.
Oh, well, I said that.
But I will also be collecting my riches.
Hopefully.
There we go, nice.
I will also be collecting my riches.
Ok, come on, take me up.
Take me home.
Don't kiss me.
Country roads...
To the place...
I belong...
So if I had just seen...
From right before that little slide, it would have been perfect.
Oh my goodness gracious.
How silly this level is.
This part is difficult.
I forgot about this.
Why is this like the toughest...
Why is this so tough?
I hope you are having a great day, Mint.
I am!
You too!
Thank you!
Happy weekend!
Happy...
Weekend!
Goodness gracious, great balls of fire!
Spare no snowman.
No snowman left alive.
Oh, it did work!
I see, I see now.
Goodness gracious, great balls of fire!
I love dynamite!
Nice.
And we'll take our money too.
I'm rich?
I don't know.
I don't have that much gacha.
Nice.
Alright, alright.
We first timed it this...
That guy...
I always...
You know what?
Good.
Good enough.
That guy is literally teetering.
Are you OK buddy?
Are you going to make it?
Is that why you are a dynamite gal?
Alright, we got this.
Hello?
There we go.
It still worked.
Still worked out.
We are almost there!
We are almost there.
We are almost back to the spot.
That was close.
Nice.
See?
Speedrun.
Speedrun everybody.
Oh my goodness, I forgot about these guys.
OK!
Speed!
Frigid for... Oh, I have to go inside your head?
The music though.
It's so crazy.
Opposite way.
It's so beautiful.
Why is it so beautiful?
Raiders.
Thank you for the...
Thank you.
Sorry, I have to zoom in.
Because it's white on white text.
I don't know why YouTube is like this.
It's so horrible.
We are playing Astro Bot and I think I'll probably finish it today.
Which means like finishing all the worlds.
Zaki, thanks for the gift.
Yeah, screw you.
Why are you so happy now?
And that is another world, baby.
Another world!
K-5!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
OK, alright.
We got this one.
Oh, you sneaky little seal, you.
OK, OK.
I get it.
10 gifted!
K-3, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Damn, I'm late.
No you're not.
It's all good.
Ah.
Yay!
We have, I guess, 3 more and then the boss.
Which is all the main worlds.
I suppose maybe there might be one more after the boss.
The boss.
Crash, thanks for the 10 gifted.
I wanna go back home real quick and do some gacha though.
I want to get, maybe hopefully, a snake outfit if there is one in existence.
245 out of 300!
Oh my gosh.
We're killing it, you guys.
We're really killing it here.
Oh, that's wrong.
What are you doing?
Oh, there he goes.
He was stuck!
Help me.
Help me, Minto.
I'm stuck.
We're also wanting Raiden Sword.
Little green men!
Trust you as far as you can throw them.
They're so cute.
Outfit.
Skelly!
Nothing to hide.
I kinda love it.
I think we'll change into the Skelly outfit after this.
What is this?
A door?
Loading door.
Cute!
It's so cute actually though.
Is that a golf club?
Bunker, Buster and Ball.
Can't see under the skirt though.
Fishy!
Rescued fish.
Look at him with his stinking coin.
Was there a fish in Detroit Become...
Was there a fish in Detroit Become Human?
In the very beginning.
Is that an important part of the game?
We can become a rapper!
Wait, it's so cute!
Ok, nevermind.
Ignore the Skelly outfit everybody.
Wait, we got another outfit?
My, what big ears you have.
They're not that big.
Another outfit?
Guys, I think I have to be Ape Escape.
I think I have to become Minky.
Minky!
Raiden!
Raiden, come home!
I hate this game.
Raiden!
Wait...
I
was like, I think that's him!
I think...
We bought officially all the Metal Gear stuff in the game baby!
Who wants a slice?
Oh my goodness, I'm so happy.
Restraint Remnants.
Yeah, be free.
Another outfit?
I could become a cowgirl.
My soul is a tool of justice.
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Hello Doki Bird.
Come on!
What's this one?
Memory Recorder.
Why does he look so distressed?
Royal Guardian and Fallen Fruit.
Has stars in his eyes.
Does he really?
I don't see that.
I wonder if there even is a Metal Gear outfit then.
So sad.
He ran out of ink.
Oh OK, that would be a reason to be distressed, huh?
That would be a reason to be distressed.
Memory Recorder, thanks for the gift!
Let's go check out Raiden.
The shell and all.
Raiden is gonna be growing trees in his tummy.
Raiden!
He's like, I'm a fat boy.
Oh my god!
That was so silly.
Who of two Wisps do you want to see fight each other?
And why would it be a better fight than last night?
Last night?
Wait...
We only have two outfits left you guys.
I don't think there's... What if there's no Metal Gear outfit?
What if there's no Metal Gear outfit?
Last night was Jake Paul vs Mike Tyson.
Oh yeah!
I saw...
Oh my god!
I'm a monkey!
This is the best game ever.
I saw nothing about it.
I saw a clip of them introducing Mike Tyson.
What's this?
Ah!
I think I remember this one.
It looks so cursed.
And like...
He like grabbed his crotch for some reason really aggressively.
I saw the clip of his butt.
His butt?
Mike Tyson had his ass out.
Fun fact about Dante Bot.
He was originally supposed to be Leon Kennedy Bot.
But the devs decided he was too silly.
I believe you.
Yeah, it looks like we got all the warps.
It said 2 out of 2 so there's no other warps in this.
Thank goodness.
Dive on in.
I think today I definitely want to collect at least every bot.
Oh no, sorry.
That's a lie.
Every bot from the main.
Not from the challenges.
Every bot from the main levels.
I'm not a masochist.
But you know...
OK, anyway.
Charming though.
I hear you!
Minky!
Minky rescue!
Minky here for the rescue!
I don't hear anything else.
Minky rescue time!
What is...what's this?
Oh my gosh.
It's a time for the adults now.
Children, go to bed.
The pool is closed.
This sounds very like Toy Story, doesn't it?
This feels like a Toy Story sort of level.
No, not yet.
Oh my goodness.
Wait a second.
Wait, I want that bird to come back out.
I'm trying to...
Oh
my god.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to hit him!
Oh my god.
OK, I give up.
Oh, they're glowing.
Girl, you are glowing.
Who is that?
I think we need it to be daytime.
Oh, I have this thing again.
OK, OK.
We go up this way.
I understand, I understand.
Oh no.
Out!
I was going to say, where the heck am I?
OK, we got this guys.
We got this, we got this.
There's going to be more than you had to jump on.
Papercraft Posty.
It has a very important message for you.
What is this?
Minto knows what she wants.
Metal gear, I know.
Tear away.
Was there anything else with this?
Any secrets?
Any secrets around?
I don't think so.
I hear someone else screaming.
I think.
Maybe it's me.
No, it's definitely not me.
Oh my god.
In my face?
Why would you do that?
Miso gear everybody.
I think I just killed a person.
Actually I'm not sure.
Are you still alive?
Which way do I go?
OK, definitely not this way, but what if there is a guy over there?
Yeah, there is a secret, see?
There is a secret.
No way!
He's still... I still hear something, right?
I think.
I think I still hear a guy.
Hopefully.
Ah, see?
He was here the whole time.
No, he's not gone forever.
We got him.
Wait.
Yeah, see?
I was actually stressing a little.
Oh, this damn bird.
Bait him and...
Nice.
Oh my god, please don't kiss me.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We got him.
Imagine if I just left him.
Like, if I just not taking care of those guys.
Nice try.
Hold on.
One second.
They gave me way more time than I thought they would.
Oh no!
What's this?
More secret.
And I can kill things from far away.
Nice.
What the hell?
This is a new guy.
And I'm not even going to give him the time of day to know what he'll do.
I'm not even gonna give him the time of day.
Okay.
So far so good.
So far so great!
So far so grand!
Yeah!
New guy more like dead guy.
So true.
Call him out.
Oh god.
I
think that's everything.
Wait, there's this here?
Money?
Lots and lots of it.
I heard my name.
Did you?
Thanks for paying attention to the stream.
You sure did hear your name.
In fact, I might call out your name any second.
Look at their playing ball over there.
I might just look in chat and be like...
Rowlet!
And then you have to pay attention.
Kuronagi!
Pirate505!
That's cheating.
How is it cheating?
I'm just telling you that...
I'm paying attention.
Or rather, you'll know if you hear your name...
if you're paying attention, you know?
What kind of dealio?
It's like such a mystery.
Will Minto ever call my name?
I gotta pay attention all the time!
It's kind of that sort of situation.
Is all.
So I don't go the other way, right?
Bet.
What do you mean bet?
Nice.
How am I doing on puzzle pieces so far, guys?
Today could be the day.
Today is your lucky day, trash boy!
She won't see me.
I always see you, Shiro.
I always see you.
Oh boy.
I was gonna say, this feels like that one thing when I was trying to get Raiden.
Oh my god.
Is that guy yawning or is he broken?
Is he so sleepy he can barely keep his eyes open?
Nice.
I killed him, but I don't know how.
Ducky!
Oh my goodness.
We look so happy.
Hold on!
I'll get you!
Somehow.
How do I... How do I get him?
We are being perceived!
I am perceiving!
Oh there it is.
I just completely missed it.
That's so funny.
The wire.
I didn't see it.
Alrighty.
Awesome!
Anything else around here?
Where did that guy climb from anyway?
Okay.
This is such a silly level.
God, that scared the heck out of me.
Oops.
They're rolling, they're rolling.
Oh, I missed it.
Hi.
Hi Ducky.
Big money!
I feel like I'm stealing from their bank account when I do that.
Nice!
Got the puzzle piece and everything.
We'll get them this time.
Clever, clever.
This game is so clever.
We're missing one guy and one puzzle piece.
Alright.
One guy.
One puzzle piece.
That was too close for comfort everybody.
That was way too close for comfort.
I think I just killed some guys.
I think I just killed some people.
I heard them scream as they fell to their death.
So sad.
Good job.
Thank you.
I think there's probably something down here.
Secret!
Look at these guys.
They're so cute.
Low poly enemies.
Oh no!
I got you.
After I get my money first.
Where is my money?
Secret!
Hello?
Where do I go from here?
Oh here.
I'm getting dizzy.
I have no idea where I'm at.
I have no idea.
Here?
That's a lot of money.
Hi!
One second!
Let me get my money!
Alright.
And collect our little guy.
No way.
Oh it's Sackboy.
I thought... Wait.
I thought... Is that the guy's... Is that the name of the little big planet guy?
Is that the name of the little big... Yes?
That's kind of messed up.
They replaced him with this game.
Knitted Kid.
Such a crafty little guy.
Oh my god!
I got all the stuff for the...
Oh, we can only go one way out.
I got all the Metal Gear DLC.
For little big planet.
In case you were curious.
If you're like... Oh no!
I wonder if Minto knew about it.
Of course I did.
And I got it up.
Never doubted?
That's right.
Though I appreciate so many people will send me...
They'll tag me in Metal Gear stuff.
Even if I already know or something.
Oh coins!
Money in the sky!
I just always appreciate you guys thinking of me and tagging me and stuff.
Money in the sky.
I can go twice as high.
This is dangerous.
The Wisp Network.
The sun comes up so fast.
Rip.
Rip the...
Rip to the poor salary man who's just like...
Time to go to work.
Time to go to sleep.
This is how it actually feels like when you work like a job.
Where's the last puzzle piece?
I missed it.
Where could it be?
Where was it?
Too real.
Is it on the moon?
I don't know.
Moon?
I missed it.
Where could it... Where was it?
Oh well.
I don't think this is made of cheese.
Oh.
Next!
It was close to the last bot.
Dang it.
That was a pretty long chapter I feel too.
Pretty long level so...
It's ok.
Cannon brawl.
This one does not have a lot of PlayStation characters.
A lot of normies.
This is not what I expected.
Wait.
Oh no!
I still got it.
I still got it!
Thanks for 7 months!
I didn't get the money, but I got the...
I got the puzzle piece and I think that's all that really matters.
Shoot.
There we go.
Fade him and...
Oh.
What are these?
Take him down?
How much can I take down?
Oh I have to make my own pathway.
Was there going to be a Minto merch release next?
Or did I misunderstand?
No, you didn't misunderstand at all Riko.
You didn't misunderstand at all.
I just have to...
There's like a few things we're waiting on.
Oh my god.
What is this one?
Oh this is when I can roll around.
That's right.
Minto still got it.
I still got it baby!
This is not what I expected.
I thought we were going to have like a pirate ship thing going on.
Idiot!
I might have gotten insta-karma'd.
I might have had a bounce of insta-karma there.
He'll run out eventually!
Yeah!
See?
I came in here at the perfect time.
Welcome.
Thank you for dropping by.
Guys...
Guys, am I too silly?
We're
fine!
Oh no, we're not fine.
We're not fine!
We're not fine, but we're fine at the same time.
It's okay, just take it!
Yeah!
What is this song?
Normal amount of silly.
That's so good.
Because my doctor said if I'm too silly anymore...
That's the end of it for me.
Oh.
Alright, hold on.
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to do this?
Come here!
Terminal silly syndrome?
Wait, how the heck am I supposed to...Oh, I'm supposed to be a little ball.
Duh.
The gimmick of this level.
I'm supposed to utilize it!
Yeah.
Alright.
Become ball.
We're balling, we're balling, we're...balling?
Is he gonna let go of me or...
Or am I...Uh oh.
I'm like ripping my...
Oh my gosh.
Arc stone explorer has a tendency to see things in black and white.
Your silly organ is depleted.
I'm running on silly fumes!
Is that Mr. Demon Souls?
An honor.
This is an absolute honor, sir.
Uh oh.
I saw it though.
Oh no!
No!
I got you!
I need a silly transplant!
It's getting...The diagnosis is getting worse and worse by the day!
There we go.
Okay, hold on.
Nice.
Wait!
I don't think I was ready to go...
Nevermind.
I had to go.
We were gonna go down with that ship.
We were literally gonna go down with that ship.
Silly syndrome treatment fund.
Thank you!
What's over here?
Secret.
Oh my gosh!
It's him!
Wait, it's a Papa Pirate.
This one.
Ahoy, Papa Pirate.
Yay!
You killed him?
He was already dead.
It was literally Skelly.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
We've gotten all the guys in a row so far.
All of our little men in a row.
Okay.
Alright.
See you later.
Rats.
The rats led us to the destination.
Okay.
We're strong.
Nice.
What's this bird doing?
Do you have any things you wanna tell me?
I didn't.
I didn't think he was gonna release.
Good evening, Mintonio.
Good evening.
That is my name.
That is indeed my name.
Does fire happen in this?
Oh my god!
Suck me up!
I like this one because it feels like you basically become invincible.
Wait a second.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait.
Oh shoot!
What did I miss?
You can still go back?
I can't!
I can't go back.
Oh no!
Top of the crushers?
What's the crushers?
Oh, death by lava.
True.
Oh, checkpoint.
Alright.
Wait.
That crusher?
Oh, I see.
I wonder if I can roll back.
It's okay.
I will just continue.
I'll beat the level.
It wasn't that far.
That's crazy because there is a checkpoint literally right here.
So they gave me a checkpoint even though they didn't tell me it's a checkpoint.
It's a fake checkpoint.
Suck what?
Suck on this!
Say hello to... Oh my god.
Say hello to my little fist.
I think if I jump here...
Yeah, like that.
Hold on.
Money first.
Then help the people.
I'm so salty!
Can't believe I missed that guy.
No, no.
There we go.
Wait, is this where I'm supposed to go?
I almost missed the puzzle piece!
I thought I was finding the secret.
Oh my gosh.
I'm walking the plank!
That was a close call, yeah.
Matey.
Hold on.
I'm too scared.
What if I...
What if my little body is too heavy to sink to the ground?
This is what happens when you double, triple, quadruple caress me.
You guys wouldn't happen to be landlubbers, right?
Because that would be awful.
Oh no, no, no!
This is timed!
My body!
You guys wouldn't happen to be landlubbers, would you?
Why did it get so quiet all of a sudden?
No,
Captain Short Fuse!
I think I'm supposed to...
I'll just...
Got him!
Oh, come on.
Oh my god, that was so close!
Okay, we got that guy.
Okay, we'll wait for it to come back again.
That was a close one for real.
Holy cow!
Dang it!
If I just hadn't messed up that jump...
I messed up the jump, it's my fault.
I didn't realize that they were going up and down so high.
Okay, come on.
Come on!
I'm gonna just wait here.
Did that work?
Okay.
This will destroy at least one of them.
Alright, I'm gonna wait again.
Nice eyepatch, thank you.
I'm no landlubber.
And he comes again.
Perfect.
Then I have to go back again.
There we go.
I'll be back.
Oh, I should...
That was gonna kill me.
Wait, I missed two guys!
I think there was a guy probably... I think that one guy actually probably died in that sinking ship.
I think that guy died in that sinking ship.
He was on the sinking ship?
Oh no!
We're gonna have to go through this all the way again.
Oh, that sucks.
A captain always goes down with his ship.
We should go back for them though.
We should go back for them.
You can quit after you get that guy.
Yeah, it's so true, so true.
More money!
Thank you!
Why pay money for help when you have chat who will help.
I believe you will help.
Okay, sorry guys.
Sorry that I have to do this all over again.
Sorry.
Alright, I'm just gonna do this for a bit.
This should be good.
Right?
Why isn't it...
We are the backseat kings!
We will...
We'll just...
Speedrun to the location.
See,
he kills those guys.
That's crazy.
Oh, dang it.
I almost had him.
I can still get him.
For the money.
I think it's like $2, but whatever.
Okay.
Alright.
Where was it at again?
Not over here.
Oh, I see.
Wait, there was starting at a big...
Oh, no.
Oh, man.
I missed my money.
Missed my chance on the big dollars.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
It's right here, right?
Okay.
I hear him.
I hear someone.
No, maybe it's me.
Is he inside?
No, I hear him.
I hear...
Above the crushers.
How the heck am I supposed to get up there?
Oh,
my god.
I don't like this angle very much.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe from here?
Oh, wait.
That's right.
I can do this.
Is that him?
Oh, goodness.
Secret.
Oh, my god.
So glad that this thing is so sensitive.
It listens so well.
I got you!
What the hell is this?
Nexus Dweller.
If you got the souls, she's got the stats.
Jane Demon Souls.
I had a feeling it was all the way up here.
But I wasn't sure.
Alright, now we just got to rescue.
A poor little sap on a bridge.
On a ship.
And then we'll be good to go.
My money.
Okay.
Are you still missing a puzzle piece?
I don't think so.
I think I got all of them.
Yeah.
We got all of them for this level.
I thought we did.
He's over there.
Somewhere.
He's in there.
Just gonna take all this money.
Since we're here.
Actually, oh my god, how cool would it be if we walk the plank?
Wait.
Look at the axe!
That's so cute!
We walk the plank into opening it up.
Watch this, watch this.
Just had a very minty mojito with my shrimp crepes in white wine sauce.
I finished with a bourbon toffee cake a la mode.
How do you know so much to cook?
Kinki's always eating the best stuff, man.
I don't understand.
How?
Ok, here we go.
We won't rest until we find our son!
Oh, there he is!
He was hidden amongst the jewels.
We got him!
Time to go home.
I think I need to get my eye drops.
100% baby!
259 out of 300.
That's crazy.
Oh my god!
We're not going there just yet.
We're going here.
Orbital blitz.
41.
I don't think we're going to be able to get all of them though.
Because I'm scared of the...
I'm really so nervous for the...
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I'm scared for the challenge levels.
You know.
Is there something you get?
I don't think so.
I'm not sure actually.
There we go, baby.
I'm scared for the challenge levels.
Mainly.
I thought the... what's it called?
Ran out.
What's it called?
The boost.
Which is why I was kind of silly with it.
But it doesn't.
I hear you!
There are some easier challenge levels you can do.
Yeah, but...
Oh, they're doing this thing up again.
If I can't get...
Oh, I think I need to hop over here.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
If I can't get all of them, then it's like...
If I can't get all of them...
I don't know.
There is a reward for getting all the bots and puzzle pieces.
Prototype pilot.
With speed like this, who needs a weapon?
John Wipeout.
These trees remind me of that guy from My Hero Academia.
I hate that guy.
He's so stupid.
That guy sucks.
The degenerate?
Yeah, but he's not even fun.
I can appreciate a good degenerate.
Yeah, he even wears a diaper.
He's so lame.
Everything about him is so lame.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Just got here.
What is this combo?
Have you ever watched My Hero Academia?
The trees remind me of that guy with the hair that looks like grapes.
I must confess that the meal was not mine.
Oh.
I'm out for a concert tonight and decided to treat myself before it started in an hour.
Figured I'd watch you as much as I could before they started.
Go enjoy your concert.
What are you doing?
Watching an anime girl play Astro Boy when you're about to...
Cock-a-doodle-doo, baby!
What does this one do again?
Oh, okay.
It makes us go up.
So I can get that.
Holy...
Express delivery.
Sorry.
You'll never shoot me!
Oh, nevermind.
That's embarrassing.
Anyway...
Guys, that was just a practice run, okay?
That was just a practice run.
Oh, shoot.
Ow, shoot!
Oh my god.
I didn't jump soon enough.
S.S.D.
They don't even do the normal spiky guys anymore.
They only do the extreme spi...
Oops, I forgot to get the other ones.
They only do the extreme spiky ones now.
More practice.
Yeah!
S.S.D.
Oh my gosh, I got stuck!
This game used to be such easy for babies.
What happened?
Now they're like, oh by the way, we're gonna send three of these crazy enemies at you.
Oh my god, that one almost hit me!
How is that even possible?
Money.
I wonder if I can get them from below, you know?
If I can go down here.
If I can hit them from below.
What is this?
Space pups.
315 bots total.
Really?
Where's my guy?
I hear somebody.
Alright, we're gonna go for the green.
Nevermind, we're going for the red.
Where is it?
I can't see anything.
Oh there it is.
Where are you?
Where?
Is
he gonna fall?
What am I throwing this at?
Something.
Oh my god, I can't see anything, please!
What am I throwing?
That up there?
Maybe?
There.
People bot!
Maybe I...
Do this.
Hold on.
Wait.
Maybe I do this and maybe I float on the ball to get out.
I think.
Oh, just use the chicken.
I think you're right.
I forgot.
You're so right.
I forgot that that's what he did.
Sweaty anti-grav ace.
A friend in speed is a friend indeed.
Nice.
Hello pups.
Alright, let's see if I can get these guys from below.
Watch this.
I think I might be a genius.
How do I get out of here?
Wasn't there...
Yeah.
What is this guy?
Oh, I think I remember him.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
So smart, Minko.
I know.
Jump.
That's our thing.
Oh no, no, no.
I don't like this.
Alright.
Why are all these so difficult?
Oh my god.
No, no.
There's not enough space on here for you and me.
Okay, I think we gotta take care of the alien first.
I think we gotta take care of the alien first.
Tricky guy.
Please, let me hit you.
Okay.
Alright, now we're good.
Now let him do his thing.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
And... Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
There's a guy over there!
We missed him!
Good thing I looked.
Oh, I can... Ew, ew.
Ew.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Oh my gosh.
Please, let me stand on you.
Oh, these are so nasty.
Oh my god.
I got you!
Oh, it's so gross.
Speed freak.
If you have the power, you don't need to be smart.
You can stand on me.
Oh, I forgot I have my... I don't think I need my eyepatch anymore.
If you have the freak, you don't need to be smart.
We just saved that guy's life.
How, though, do we do this part is my confusion.
Maybe if I jump...
Like that.
Did I get any of... No!
We missed a big one.
If I fall and jump again.
Let's try it.
I was greedy!
Do I have to do this again?
Okay, no.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
Okay.
But
it's not doing it.
I'm not
close enough.
See, I'm trying to do this into this, but it's not working.
Am
I stupid?
Use my lasers to get over here.
Oh, bye cow!
Anybody?
Oh, yes, there was something up here.
That's right.
Which berry do I want to land on here?
This one.
Look at the planet!
So cool.
You don't need it?
I do need it.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Okay.
Nice!
That was a good amount.
Alright, let's not get hit by this guy.
What?
You want me to jump up here?
Got it.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Now fall.
No!
We're safe.
Nice.
Checkpoint doko.
Right!
Checkpoint!
I didn't think I was going to make that for a second.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Suck it up!
How do I...
Fun!
Can I suck up the coins?
Suck up anything else?
Puzzle piece.
Nice suck.
Guys, we're like... We're in space.
We're in space space.
We're in space space right now.
What did that guy just take?
Just the corners?
Nice checkpoint.
That was so dirty!
That was so dirty.
Goodbye cow.
Oh I see them.
God.
I see them now.
You're a people monkey.
Yeah, I'm missile gear.
I have to go get my eye drop soon in a second.
Oh gosh.
How am I supposed to get that puzzle piece?
How am I supposed to get this?
Fall and boost.
Yeah, it's gonna be...
Still count.
Still count!
So we still got it.
You know what?
It's fine.
It's still... It's fine.
I'm not gonna be greedy.
Go back for the coin.
No!
I'm not greedy!
It's one coin.
Oh cute!
This game is...
I thought they were coming for me for real.
Yeah,
take that!
Does that say Asobi?
It does!
How many are we missing?
Wow, we're missing quite a few guys.
And then one puzzle piece.
OK.
I messed up.
Greedy Yoshi is not greedy anymore.
Why?
Do you want me to be greedy still?
What's here?
I see you!
Got him!
Never be satisfied, Mito.
We want you to... Wait, 2 onions!
You're back to 2 onions!
You're not dead anymore!
Wait, I missed two?
That's big news.
Oh my gosh, I see there's so much stuff over there.
OK, we're gonna go back.
Don't worry guys.
OK, we're fine, we're fine.
OK, we're gonna go back.
Top of the tunnel.
Top of the tunnel to him.
Alright, let's see.
OK, not that way.
I see one!
How the hell do I get up there though?
Oh wait, I think I go through...
I think I go through here.
Oh my gosh, no way.
OK.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, let's get this guy too.
OK,
they both give me money.
Let's go.
Alright, so that's one guy.
OK, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
And the other guy is right there!
We see him.
Good job team.
But these guys...
Oh, I think I have to blast through the...
Oh my gosh, that was close.
I think I have to blast through the top.
So I think I can just do this.
There we go!
We got him!
Future Racer, watch where you're aiming that super missile!
And then I saw that over there.
Oh, and lots of coins.
OK, let's go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, it still counts that I got them though, right?
It still counts, right?
Look at this happy jumpy...
You son of a bitch!
No!
Got it.
OK.
We are officially...
Good.
Good to go.
Never gets old.
We're officially back on track, everybody.
Officially good to go.
Hot to go.
H-O-T-T...
This one's gonna be a little tricky.
O-G-O...
Ah!
OK, nice.
Got him.
Thanks for the hot dog!
I think there's something just below this checkpoint too.
Is there now?
Good eye!
Super fly Dan Fry!
Good eye, for real.
Good eye.
No!
Oh my gosh, where is he taking him?
Where did he take him?
Oh my god, he's up there.
Nice.
First try.
And that's all our bots, baby!
Now we just need...
The...
Now we just need the...
We're fine!
We just have one last puzzle piece.
Which I'm...
Searching for.
I wish...
I wish this game would allow you to go back to checkpoints once you beat a level, you know what I mean?
I think that's like the one thing...
That would make it perfect.
You know?
There we go, got it.
I think that's the one thing that would make it more...
You know?
Good.
100% the level first try!
Hold on, I want the money from it.
I want the money from it, there we go, okay.
Alright.
You had to say it.
Astro's playroom had that, I wonder why they didn't keep it.
Hmm, I don't know.
I mean, it's...
The game is...
It's very generous with its checkpoints.
So maybe they figured...
It'd be fine...
But like, just to have it, so you can 100% things more easily...
You know?
That's why I would like it.
Look at him, he's ready to eat me up!
He's like...
Yeah, I got him though.
Stupid.
We got everything, yeah, okay.
What's up here?
Cool.
What?
Okay!
Alright!
Uberfo.
Okay.
No, I don't like these.
What the heck is this?
Am I supposed to like...
Do this?
No, oh wait.
When he does that...
I'm slow, I'm too slow.
Yeah, yeah, there we go, there we go.
Oh my gosh, there's so many of them!
And then...
Oh dang it, I'm too slow.
I'm too slow!
Oh no, I hit the bunnies!
The bunnies scare me!
Oh my god.
They're kind of blowing up the bunnies though, which is awesome.
Dang it.
No!
Oh my god, there's too many of them.
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
My hands are so sweaty.
Let's go back home for a second.
How long have I been streaming for?
Oh my god, three and a half hours.
I love this game.
It's so easy to just stream forever.
Wait, where did that shooting star go?
Hello?
Am I bad at games?
There we go.
Let's go back real quick.
And then we'll go here, dive on in.
I know, there's puzzle pieces even on the map.
I wonder how many we do need left.
Oh my god, less than 40.
One, oh nevermind.
I was gonna...
I think it's like all the way over there, so I don't really quite feel like going that direction.
Eye drops?
Yeah, I'm gonna get my eye drops in just a second.
And then I'm gonna... I gotta go to the bathroom too.
Federation of Falcon!
The pinnacle of European engineering!
Look at the little bunny, so cute.
What's this?
Oh my gosh!
Fridges!
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, you scared...
Cute,
cute, cute.
American heavyweight.
Barely defies gravity.
What's this one?
When all else fails, dodge roll.
Oh my god, look at him go!
He's so cute!
Do it again, do it again, please.
Go, go, dodge...
Oh my god, it's so cute.
Oh my god, it's so precious.
Oh my god, Nerissa!
Often mistaken for a raven.
Wow, she's hot.
But she's not a raven.
Brazilian bullet.
Oh my god!
Knight's javelin.
This... Oh wait, you can throw this lance alive.
Get it?
So cute.
Yeah, we are interrupting something with that guy.
Oh my god, they all get their own little ships.
The future is now.
We don't have that many left in here.
A sibling spirit.
A literal party crasher.
It looked like there was nothing in there.
Oh my gosh!
We have the little gun.
Cute.
He's getting white girl...
White girl wasted up in here.
I didn't know that the astrobots were allowed to drink.
Wait, are we almost out?
Letter jacket.
It's a powerful personal message for its recipient.
We're almost out.
Even ghosts need to relax sometimes.
It's true.
Snake.
It's almost snake.
Close enough.
Ah!
A little big planet.
A little replica of a big planet.
That's so cute.
And last...
Burning scepter.
This eternal flame burns for a warden of the Nexus.
Empty again.
Time to find more special bots or puzzle pieces.
Okay.
Oh, puzzle pieces also gives us more gacha.
Interesting.
I wanna go see Mr. Death Stranding.
Let's go see.
Where was he?
Over here, right?
Oh my gosh.
Our planet is so bustling.
Sorry.
Look, he's going through the mud.
He's winking at me.
Baby!
Oh my gosh.
Oh the footsteps!
Oh my gosh, that's so cool!
Here they come, here they come.
That's so cool!
The baby.
Cute.
What was that?
No hitting.
You can't tell me what to do!
There's so many.
Look at one of you guys!
Okay.
Five Nights at Freddy's.
I learned something.
I learned that the last Chuck E.
Cheese with real animatronics is in California.
28 stab wounds!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28!
They still have some?
There's only one place left!
Only one Chuck E.
Cheese left with actual animatronics.
Isn't that crazy?
Oh, she's fine.
We're good.
Freaky.
Oh my god!
We keep sending them to space!
Okay, I'm gonna go get my eye drops and I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
So I'm probably gonna be gone for just a couple of minutes.
I prefer actual animatronics and they're not even like the moe-fied ones either.
They're like the real, original, nasty from the 80s animatronics.
They look so hideous.
I want to go!
I want to go so bad.
Like in a goofy movie.
Stay hydrated?
Yeah, I'm gonna get some more water.
You guys can hang out by Snake.
Tell me if he does anything funny.
Tell me if he does anything really goofy silly.
Which Snake do you want?
This one?
Do you want Raiden?
Naked?
Naked.
Oh you can see all of them from here.
There you go.
I'm waving.
Alright, I'll be right back.
Oh I can hear it from my controller.
Oh my gosh.
Crazy.
Okay.
I got
some jelly.
Raiders!
Thank you!
Sorry, I went to the bathroom.
Thanks for the raid!
Scatter!
No!
I got some jelly.
What
flavor is lemon jelly?
Alright.
Alright, we died.
We're okay.
Did they do anything cool?
Did they do anything awesome?
Alright guys.
Boner!
Oh my god!
Limpy!
So glad you're still streaming and thriving.
You have a great personality, hilarious laugh, and are a comedic genius.
Much love.
Keep it up.
I am the cutest streamer.
Thank you!
Wow!
Long time no see!
Thanks for dropping by!
Thanks for the super chat!
Return of the king.
Now a real celebrity moment right there.
I guess we do like this final...
This final battle and then we...Oh my goodness.
I'm not fast enough.
Please!
Nevermind, he's gone.
Maybe I do this final battle and then...
There's so many extra levels here.
We'll see what happens after this.
The raiders definitely weren't confused by the wall of blue $1 supplies.
Thank you!
Yeah, final.
I say final.
There's always like an actual boss after these ones.
Fat bird.
I hate these guys because I have to wait.
It's fine if I can just stand behind them.
Why does it sound so peaceful?
Fat bird!
Fat bird.
Oh I'm a ball again!
Nice.
There we go.
A little worrisome.
Why do I need to be a ball?
Nice.
Angry Kiwawa noises!
I'm not...No!
It's good they are on the menu.
She wants some juicy and plump, right?
What is this?
That's fine.
We haven't had that before.
We haven't had to like reverse.
We haven't had to do this on something that wasn't an enemy.
I like it.
Chimpkin.
Yeah, exactly!
Ok, it's just the one guy.
Surely we'll know.
Falcon McFly!
Oh shoot.
Oh nasty.
Oh god!
Oh my god.
I can't do anything.
Ok, nice.
There we go.
Ok.
More?
Oh I think I have to go to this side.
I just hear...
I hear...Ok, ok, I hear, I hear.
Oh my gosh!
What's this?
Oh my god.
This is craziness.
So gross!
Ok, don't be a ball for this moment.
This is bad.
This is bad, bad.
Oh I can do it while they're...Oh ok.
I thought I had to wait.
Ok, alright.
Let's go to this side.
Oh my god.
Nevermind.
Oh!
Ok.
Now I go to...I hear...Oh my gosh.
I hear it, I hear.
Two birds with one stone!
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit.
Yeah, kill those guys for me.
Thank you.
Oh my god, no!
It didn't work.
Why not?
You know what?
I'm just gonna run to it.
I'll just die, right?
Ok.
I think I need to be...Alright.
Oh, nevermind.
Alright, become ball.
Yeah, he's angry.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Oh gosh.
Ok, not be a ball here.
Alright, alright.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ok, oh.
Oh my god!
Why do you have all these guys in your beak?
Or why you...
Why are all these guys in your stomach?
Why do you have all your family in here?
I'm confused.
Oh shoot.
That was so close.
Nice!
Nice, nice.
Ok.
We're going, we're going, we're going, we're going.
You laid
an egg in your distress.
You laid an egg.
Who is it?
Who is this?
Who?
What an irresponsible driver not paying attention to the road, right?
Oh my god, my eye drops did nothing.
Sucks.
I guess we just leave.
I think my chat is frozen.
One second.
This is... What's it called?
What's that?
I know this one.
I don't remember what it's called though.
Horizon!
Thank you.
One sec.
Oh, YouTube is all frozen.
This happens to me every stream.
All the time.
My YouTube freezes.
Every day.
Every time.
It's not like I'm supposed to be a professional out here.
No.
Just screwing up always.
Making an utter fool of myself.
Oh my god, you guys.
My videos have hit 10 million views.
Yippee!
Thanks.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we got the chat back.
Wowee, that's a lot of views.
Okay, here we go to this world.
Machine learning.
Let's go in.
Wow, it's so cute.
10 million.
Bonk, bonk.
No, I missed it.
Restart.
I'm just gonna boost the entire way.
Ouch.
It's okay.
Nice.
We got it.
Thank you.
Look how cute it is.
Oh my gosh.
So beautiful, so majestic.
Is Horizon any good?
It's like they give a couple of the...
Oh, hello.
It's alright.
They give like some...
some worlds like...
special, you know, like some properties a special world.
The other one we had was...
My boy.
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh.
Awesome.
Oh, I have to aim?
Oh, hell yeah.
We have distance now.
Nice.
Wow.
I'm gonna snipe everything.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, I'm gonna fall into the water.
And slip around and not know how to run or walk or do anything.
I'm a baby.
Where are these guys?
Music is good.
My last stream actually got copyright because it was a remix of a...
Oh shit.
It was a remix of...
Of the God of War song, so it had a copyright strike on it.
Isn't that crazy?
Alloy can see recorded holograms.
Holograms.
Yeah, but it's okay.
Oh, I can't see.
There we go.
It's kind of tricky aiming with my controller.
Oh, it slows down everything too.
That's fun.
We're sniping?
Is there anything else?
Lizard?
Oh, it even shows me.
Like, see, it turns blue when I hit.
Yucky!
Minky!
Welcome to Mamba Shota!
Thank you!
I don't think there's anything else around here.
Minky!
Yucky!
I like the music a lot though.
So much for me sniping.
What's this?
Okay.
Alright, well let's go that way first because it seems that way is the main road and this is a little side road to get our buddy over here.
On the wall?
I think you shot a bot down.
I did?
No, I think I shot down a lizard.
Right?
We'll see in a second.
Ah, see, this is our first guy.
Loyal Oseram.
As dependable an ally as they are a fighter.
No one else here, right?
How far can we snipe?
What's the drop-off?
Damn.
Nice.
Alright.
Froggy!
Sniper wolf.
I am not a good shot.
But I'm an okay sniper if I have a shot.
If I have a shot, sniping is my only shot.
Typically.
Nice.
IDK about that.
Shut up!
Let me have confidence in one thing.
Hold on.
It's hard with the controller.
Where is it?
Where did it go?
There it is.
Let me go over here.
Let's go over here and do it instead.
One shot, one kill Binko.
Exactly.
That's what they all call me.
That's what I've always been.
So is it like a...
It's like a...
A post-apocalyptic world?
Security scouter has its eye on you.
Oh look at them!
Oh no, all the salary men.
Yes.
I'll free you from your...
Oh wow.
Oh my gosh, retro.
I'll free you from your...
Look at them.
Even in death...
Even in death they are having to work.
This is so sad.
Alexa, play Despacito.
What's this?
What is that?
It says it's hitting.
But I don't know what I'm hitting.
I think... Hold on, let's try from here.
What is that?
Ah.
Okay.
Even in death...
The worker life never ends.
What kind of cruel fate is...
This?
I certainly did not pay attention enough.
Okay.
What if I jump off right here?
Is there anything in here?
I think I might have screwed myself.
There we go.
Nevermind.
I'm too close!
I'm fine.
Oh, I almost was not fine.
But I'm mostly fine.
We're mostly fine.
Actually, just come here.
Oh, never... Yeah.
Oh, you're filled with rage.
Oh, you're filled with so much.
Oh, you want to kill me.
Anything else?
I'm like, not realizing that I'm zooming in so close on their faces.
But I'm just trying to look around.
I wish I was a monkey.
Oh, you can cut it.
That makes things way easier.
Let's go over here.
There.
Oh, they're gardening.
How sweet.
What did I do?
Nice!
Second puzzle piece.
Minky is better.
I want to be Minky.
I want to return to Minky.
Hit the green things?
Yeah.
That would have made sense, huh?
Game devs hate me.
They're like, you know what, we're just going to put these giant green things in there.
Everybody who plays will know that that's what they have to hit to do it, you know?
Nobody is so dumb that they need yellow X's on where they need to go.
Nobody is that stupid.
Who is crying?
Oh my god.
Minto is the reason for the yellow tapes.
I got you!
You can't even swim.
This is so sad.
Have you met people?
I try not to.
Paternal outcast.
Trained a legendary warrior.
So wait, is this...
See?
Anything glows.
Wow!
Dead people in the car!
I think of anything goes and I'm thinking of that...
Sorry, since I watched Indiana Jones recently.
Thinking of anything goes.
Anything goes.
Can I die on this?
No.
Can I die from him though?
Can he step on me?
Not quite.
I think I'm getting chased.
Steppies.
No, don't be freaks.
Don't be freaks.
It was just an...
It was just an experiment, you know?
It wasn't that I wanted to be stepped on.
I was just experimenting with the stepping ability.
It was possible.
That's all.
Don't make it weird.
They always say that.
What's going on over here, right?
Oh, there's a guy.
I think I need just to...
There's boxes on the tree?
Oh, you're right.
Thank you.
Actually, we'll just hit the tree and see if it comes down.
Because I'm kind of lazy.
I come from six months later.
She still likes Metal Gear Solid.
Huge, if real.
Hello?
Thanks, Alan!
Thanks for six months.
There's even boxes up there.
Oh my god.
What's wrong with my controller?
Why can't...
Okay, so sometimes...
Sometimes I can turn, but sometimes I can't.
Funky.
Funky, funky.
I'll take that.
And we'll just cut all these.
So there's no incidents.
I can only turn left.
Oh my gosh.
It's you.
Not opposite Owen Wilson.
Do you aim with the tilt?
Yeah.
Because sometimes you can.
And sometimes you can't, but sometimes you can.
I gotta go up.
Zoolander.
How do I...
Give me your... Show me your secrets.
Oh, he just walks on through.
Okay, I can do that.
Just kidding, I can't do that.
Oh, I see the green.
Oh, just kidding.
Nice.
And that's all of it.
Look at the little deer.
They're not afraid of humans anymore.
Because they're machines.
They are man-made, so they are used to man.
It's kind of sad if you think about it.
Oh, I have to get...
Get up on the Hydra's back!
Oh shit.
Nice.
A moment lived in infamy.
In the history of video gaming.
The infamous Hydra's back.
Thank you.
Okay, I could have used a warning.
Did I get everything here?
I think I got it.
Okay, I just have one more guy.
But we've got all the puzzle pieces, so...
I think we'll be able to make it.
Infamy more like mintfamy.
That's a monkey.
Not what we need.
Oh my gosh.
I want to chill with the monkey.
There's our guy!
Nice.
And there we go.
Cherished wanderer.
Forever in pursuit of knowledge.
Minky!
Oh my god, he died and became Minky.
What a dream.
That guy was played by Lance Riddick.
No way!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
I don't like that it sometimes slows down and sometimes it doesn't.
That confuses me.
Ripped to a real one.
Okay, I guess I don't need to explore so much since I've basically gotten everything.
Here we go.
Oh no!
Okay, he's looking awfully excitable for... Oh my god.
Come on!
Yes, got him.
He's coming back.
Don't fall off.
Oh my god.
Please... Nice.
Metal Gear?
Oh my god, Metal Gear Rex?
Metal Gear Rex real?
Oh no, no way.
No way.
This is not possible.
Oh, he's found.
He's determined.
This is the fastest turtle in the history of turtles.
Turtles everywhere.
Are you okay?
He was literally... He was hauling such ass.
That guy.
Turtle left man.
Welcome to my mission.
Thank you.
No one will ever...
The turtle... Tortoise in the hair who?
Oh my god, again?
I thought you were... Oh my god, please.
Okay.
I missed.
Oh, he's dropping money though.
That's it?
Four hours, got a shiny Litwick.
We should name him Shiny Minto.
It's a massage.
Massage.
Astro Bot, Metal Gear Solid DLC win if only.
Why do I beautify the corpse?
Oh my god, graffiti in PS5.
Oh my gosh, it's littered with shit in there.
Hey, get out of there!
Oh.
Rescued ship part.
Oh my god, no!
It has a little alien.
Mother ship's protection covers.
The most stylish way to prevent burn up on re-entry.
There we go.
The graffiti actually looks nice.
It's kind of cute.
Oh yeah, you could name the Litwick Minky.
Minky is a perfect name.
I wouldn't mind if you guys kept calling me Minky.
Call me Minto, you can call me Mint, you can call me Minky.
Oh yeah, baby.
It's time.
I'm gonna be real sensitive here.
Wait, I kind of like the graffiti though.
It's kind of cute.
No!
I don't want to wash it off!
Oh my god, no!
No!
The octopus universe!
Lizard!
No!
Snake universe!
Monkey universe!
No!
These would be cute to sell as like actual covers for...
Oh my god, he's holding the little astronaut hostage!
My hands are getting hot.
Why is it so crunchy though?
What kind of paint do these guys use?
Alright, take out this ugly...
There's... Oh my god, there's bad guys on here!
Very good.
That's not paint.
What do you mean by that?
Can we call you Bintou?
Sure.
When did this become power wash, though?
Nice.
Oh, that one hurts my hands.
Here we go!
Screw it in, baby!
Baby!
The heart eyes down there are wild.
Look at the little robots with the heart eyes.
They're crazy.
Flip over.
The eyes are shaking.
They're like...
And last but not least...
Oh my gosh!
What is this?
Oh my gosh, where's Snake?
Snake, can you see me?
I see Pyramid Head.
No, shut up game.
I know the tutorial.
I'm looking for Snake.
Where is that guy?
Snake?
What the hell is the Persona Bear doing?
Is he OK?
Snake?
What is he doing down there?
Wait, the other ones too.
Are they OK?
I don't see Snake.
He doesn't love me anymore.
There we go.
Oh my
gosh, it's beautiful.
Oh my gosh, it's beautiful.
Welcome to the army.
Now what?
We only have 30 guys left.
Oh my gosh.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
I can't see...
Wait,
what is that?
We're still missing a piece?
Wee-woo.
Uh-oh, it's time for the wee-woo button.
They're all telling me to press it.
I'll do whatever you say, Snake.
Where are you?
Oh, hi Johnny's comrade.
Snake, I'll do whatever you tell me to.
Oh, all the Metal Gear...Oh, hello?
All the Metal Gears are...
They don't even care.
They're not even over here.
Oh man.
I'm hungry, chat.
What flavor wings should I get for dinner?
Garlic!
Is that a flavor?
Where is Snake?
This guy sucks so much.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, shut up.
This is so cute.
Stop!
Oh my god!
This is so cute!
Oh my god, PS3!
Oh my god, PS2!
Play Squadron Go?
Shoot him down!
Wait, there we go.
Yeah, shoot him down!
Oh, puzzle piece.
Puzzle piece!
I got it.
Nice.
There's even puzzle pieces here?
Oh my god.
Yeah, take him down.
Oh my god, so awesome.
Hey, watch out!
Watch out!
Oh, that was close.
Power of friendship!
Watch out!
There we go.
Take him out!
We'll help you!
Yeah, close.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the PS2!
He's so chunky!
This is so awesome!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Power of friendship!
Nice, I got another puzzle piece!
Oh
my god.
Backwards!
Oh my god.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
I don't like this.
I just hear them screaming in the background.
Oh my god.
The BME chunky!
I miss the PS2 so much.
Nice.
Puzzle piece.
I got you.
If you guys see Snake yell, ok?
Tell me the timestamp.
I wanna see that he's fighting alongside with me.
It would really mean a lot.
Tell me now if you see him.
I got you!
I got your back!
I had your back.
I tried.
I gotta also watch my back.
It's just that one guy there.
Nice.
Oops.
Ok, there we go.
There we go.
Grab all these guys.
This is insanity.
This is so fun though.
Oh my god.
There's so much going on.
I can't see anything.
There's just so much...
Hello!
Thanks for getting my back!
Snake!
Nice.
Are you in there?
We're gaming.
Watch out.
Puzzle piece.
Nice, I got the last one.
Get up!
Explode!
Nice.
Yeah.
Yeah, Mr. Evil.
The PS5!
Holy shit!
Oh no, I have hearts here.
Why do I have hearts here?
No!
There we go, space bully!
What the hell?
Oh, I get to...
What is this?
Monkey!
What does the monkey do again?
Oh my god!
That's...
You'll learn why they call me Revolver.
Oh my god.
What does the monkey do again?
Mickey!
Oh, it grabs stuff.
Oh, that's right!
We gotta grab it and shoot it at him.
Yeah, thank you.
Nice.
OK, next round!
Here we go!
That
was too slow!
There we go.
Dang it.
Oh, I think I was supposed to hit that.
Oh dang it.
I was supposed to...
Oh shoot!
I was supposed to hit it.
Oops.
It's OK, I realize after.
It's OK, we'll do it.
OK.
There we go.
Can I get the other one?
Nope.
Oh my god, this is such a long fight.
Uh oh.
What happens if I pick the death?
What happens if I accidentally land on death?
My nose is running!
Froggy!
I don't remember what Froggy does.
Wait!
You jerk!
Good.
Collect the pieces!
Collect the pieces and we'll fling the pieces!
Then we'll fling the pieces!
I'm too big!
That one wasn't so bad actually.
That one was so easy.
Was that it?
Oh my gosh!
First try!
Things complete!
Where is Snake?
He's not here.
So sad.
Wait, is he there?
Is he anywhere?
Phase 2?
I see a grey fox.
There he is!
Snake!
Oh shit!
Oh my God!
Oh no we didn't.
Snake!
No!
Oh my God!
My army!
Look at them go!
Oh my God!
So cute!
No!
Shut up, is that the ending?
Are these the credits?
He made it!
Oh my God, the fake out was real.
You guys, I actually started crying.
Oh my God, I actually started crying over these stupid little robots.
No, we have to put them back together!
Oh my God, live!
You must live!
Minky!
We have his arm!
Ok Minky.
Minky, take this.
I'll be nice and gentle about it.
Minky, are you ok?
Minky, wake up Minky!
Minky, what else do you need?
Are they offering their body parts?
They are offering themselves!
Oh my God, no!
They are offering their arms and their legs!
Minky!
Oh my God, he just already took it off.
He's like ok, I know what you need.
Minky, wake up!
Minky!
I gave you what you needed!
Minky, wake up!
Minky!
What else do we need guys?
What are you searching for?
Another heart!
Oh my God!
This is what all video games need you guys!
It's heart!
It's soul!
Minky, wake up!
Minky?
Snake is right there!
Hi Snake!
Oh my arm!
Here we go!
That guy is fighting for his life!
Pull him up!
Oh my God, the PS4!
Snake, how did you get all the way over there?
Oh yeah!
Oh
my God, interactive credits!
Wow!
We got the dog, ok.
We can get more coins here even.
The V-Dog!
No, VR!
There we go.
What if you fell off here?
What happens if you fall off here?
This is so cute!
We got the froggies.
Oh my God, uncharted.
Oh the PS3!
Oh my gosh!
Sorry, I can't stop saying wow.
I'm filled with so many emotions right now.
I'm filled with so many emotions.
Holy shit.
Oops, my bad.
Wait, what happened?
The PS3!
Well, I guess we found out what happens if you fall off.
Now we know.
Abe!
Oh
my God, the fireworks!
Oh my God, I can still collect coins?
This is ridiculous.
Astro Bot.
My friends!
The PS2!
Sorry, depth perception.
Astro Bot.
Oh
no, it's the time slow one.
I'm not good at this one you guys.
I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
Wing!
What is that?
Oh, Bot.
Oh wait, is that the PS2 Slim?
Nice!
So cute.
Oh look, there are the shapes!
What the hell is this one?
When did I ever get this?
Wee!
The PS1, wow.
Snake, are you in there?
Oh my God!
Wait, what the hell is this?
I never had these things before.
What are those?
We're good.
It's so beautiful!
Oh my God, all my friends.
Where is he?
Oh, I see Psycho Mantis.
A present?
For me?
It's so good!
Minky and Minky.
I wish they had asked my name at the beginning.
It would have been crazy if it said Minto.
Wait, hold on, I'll move.
Cute!
All the enemies.
Enemies.
Buggy Bunny, Gloopy!
Oh my God, they have names!
Oh my goodness.
I think they're...
Pumpkindle, Rooter, Triptrap, Lemmy, thanks for the gifted!
Oh my gosh, this was...
This game is so cute.
Snake!
Veno, Bolter, Wormy and Voxel.
Voxel.
I liked Roundbones.
Vulture, Shockrock... Oh, I didn't see the other name.
The one guy we saw for two seconds.
That's the Uncharted area.
That's right, that was the other world we had to go to.
It was Uncharted.
Mistletoe!
Oh, Volipop, thank you.
Thank you.
Mito!
Phanto!
Close enough.
Igni.
Dosukoi, Dosukoi.
Piranha, Snap, Snap, Tramp.
Fugu!
Oh, because it's like Fugu, that's so cute.
I hated those chameleons.
Minimon, Minileon.
Leon.
Minileon?
What is... Captain Shortview is Captain Pinscher.
Are they brother?
Wait, that was Solidus and that was...
Wait, one of them was Solidus and one of them was naked.
Frigidfrosty, Tama Trio.
The Djinn.
Djinnia the Lamb.
Chief Kawa.
You wouldn't really like Astro's playroom.
It has snake too?
No way!
Megaglooper.
Sapling.
It's so creepy.
What the hell?
Oh, I like the dinosaur.
Blunderjaw.
Astro Bot is my game of the year.
Happy to see you beat it and enjoyed it.
The end.
New galaxy discovered.
Now you can reenact the thrilling final battle as often as you like.
Nice!
It is a thrilling final battle.
New galaxy discovered.
Time to perfect your...
Time to perfect your speedrunning skills.
Speedrun time.
There was only one outfit that we missed.
Congratulations!
You rid the world of that evil bully and saved the day.
But there are still many lost bots to rescue.
Can you find them all?
One moment please.
There might be some more gacha.
There is more gacha.
We can definitely at least do these.
It's a giraffe.
Giraffe.
No new outfit though.
Malicious AI.
Loot bunny.
Oh, these are all the...
Horizon ones.
Ancient interface.
Nothing beats watching Mint on your birthday.
21 years.
Red, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Red.
Happy birthday!
Maybe we have to get a puzzle piece for the...
Maybe we have to get a puzzle piece for the last outfit.
Maybe it's not a person.
Oh my gosh, the giraffe!
Oh my gosh, this thing makes me want to play Horizon.
It's so...
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
It's actually so beautiful.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh, I can't get over how cute it is.
I can't believe I get this reference now.
I want to play so many more games so that I can come back to this and be like...
I understand this reference now.
You know?
So many more games in here so I can be like... I understand this reference.
Let's see.
I think we got... I don't know how many more we missed of these.
Just one?
Just one paint?
But I like our current one.
These streams have been so much fun.
I'm going to miss Snakebot and the rest of the gang.
Me too!
And we missed one outfit.
But...
And then I guess... Hold on.
I guess it was... The puzzle piece was all the way over here.
Like the thing that we are trying to finish.
It's right here.
We are almost done with it.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
11 pieces left.
Did you beat all the secret levels?
I did not.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
That's it?
That's all they do?
Are they even awake?
You need 250 bots to get in there?
I have way more than 250 bots.
I have like 2... How many bots do I have at this point?
270?
280?
Almost 280?
Maybe.
I still beat.
You look so good.
Where?
Open up, Snake.
Open up!
What does it say?
Solid state?
That's so silly.
Congrats on another game clear.
Thank you!
I love this.
I love that you can see the scene on the...
On the screen.
It's so good.
Oh, I'm gonna miss my little guy so much.
I'm gonna miss my guys so much.
The music makes me so emo-y.
Did you play Astro's Playroom before this?
I didn't, actually.
But this is so fun.
I know I didn't like 100% get everybody and complete all the worlds, but that's okay.
Maybe I'll come back to it, like, for just some random stream.
There's only a few.
Let's see, one.
The music's different.
One puzzle piece there.
Two.
What do you have, like, 12?
Oh, see, there's so many in this one.
Three.
Four.
I think I got all of them in here.
Are there any in here?
Oh my gosh, there's even 10 guys in here!
Try a speedway?
Okay, I'll try a speedway.
Let's try with the monkey.
There's a leaderboard!
Minky!
Okay, we already start with Minky.
Let's go!
Wait,
which way do I go?
This way?
No!
Wait, what do I do here?
Wait, how do I...
Swing!
I'm trying... I'm not... I'm... I can't... It's not letting me do anything.
Oh, I have to do it with the control...
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
We're
so close to sub 2 minutes!
2, 2, 2!
Yeah, there were guys in this.
Where were they?
Check the leaderboard.
I'm scared.
Oh wait, don't look at my profile picture.
Why?
Holy moly, I'm 100,000th.
What's the world record?
29 seconds!
Holy cow!
That's insane.
I feel self-conscious.
When you guys see my profile...
This is literally the least surprising thing ever.
I know, but I didn't expect you to see it.
Get me out of here.
I feel exposed, though.
I still feel exposed.
Nice.
Well,
we did that.
We did that.
I like the monkey one.
It's pretty fast.
I mean, fun.
New viewers, this is how you know it's not a bit.
No!
I always do it for the bit.
Did I get all the warps, at least?
I think I got all the warps.
Yeah.
I got all the warps, at least.
Hi man, this is Jukedo's cousin.
I know he mentioned his birthday last stream, but he's a shy boy and didn't ask for a birthday song.
I was hoping we could surprise him when he watches the VOD later.
You're so sweet!
Of course we can.
JAKAIDO!
Potato, potato.
I can't believe... I can't believe you're a shy boy.
I cannot believe.
I can't believe it.
Of course I will sing you happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday JAKAIDO, JAKAIDO.
Potato, potato.
Avocado.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Never feel too shy to ask for a birthday song.
I hope you enjoyed the VOD.
I hope you got this far.
Guys, I actually started crying for my little robots.
My little astrobots.
I missed them so much.
I have an astrobot fan that I got from TGS.
I'm first!
But I hope they make some plushies and stuff.
I hope they make some astrobot plushies.
I'd buy those.
Sorry princess, thank you!
They had those?
Yeah!
They did.
Wait...
It's somewhere in my room.
I have it somewhere.
I had to get one.
I was like, I need the astrobot.
All three of their popcorns.
Oh, you too.
I got it!
Oh my god, the monkey is so close.
I'm just trying to look at our PS5.
I love the controller, but it's so expensive.
Wait, astrobot controller?
I haven't seen it.
There's an astrobot Nendo?
Really?
Seriously?
I want one so... I want little astrobot plushies so bad.
My little astrobots.
Hey, stop sleeping on the job!
They're laughing at him.
What happened?
Why are they laughing at him?
What's wrong?
What happened?
Why are these guys meditating under here?
There's so much going on.
Oh my gosh, I've never been such a fan of a mascot before.
Oh, he had no arms?
I forgot that the triangle calls for them.
Wait.
Oh no, I guess we'll never know if he had no arms or not.
Oh my god, they're all here!
Wait, let's go to a good spot and wish our little astrobots farewell.
It feels like Mother Base.
I know, right?
Oh, hi Spyro.
Raiden?
Or Snake?
Tell me where he is.
Within this group of... Oh my gosh, there's so many of them.
Look at our army.
Oh, there he is!
Fellow astrobots!
It has been an honor...
fighting alongside you!
Press down to dance?
Let's dance!
Oh my gosh, bot-bot revolution.
Oh whoops, I didn't mean to do that.
Wait.
Hold on.
Keep dancing!
This has been such a fun game.
Sorry it took me so long to beat.
Because I would have some times when I wouldn't stream it in a week or something would happen.
But I'm so glad we could at least complete the game.
Oh my gosh, I'm doing like the Carlton.
No, so much fun.
So, so much fun.
Look at Big Boss over there.
Wow!
Thanks for the fun playthrough.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
That's so much fun.
Maybe I'll come back and get the rest of the puzzle pieces or something.
Or I'll film myself getting the final puzzle piece.
I'll record it or something and I'll post it somewhere.
Something.
Or maybe if I go out of town again.
Actually, that's a good idea.
I could record a VOD.
I could record it for when I go out of town and then I can just post it.
So I'll do that sometime.
I feel like it's been a while since I've seen a game filled with so much love.
It really makes me so happy to see.
I know!
Thank you for playing this, Mintos.
It's been a lot of fun.
Thanks, Takezo!
Let's not think about those 38 bots still stuck on those planets.
I'll get them.
And then I'll record...
Nobody is immune to the floss.
Everybody must floss together.
Spyro is not a part of this though.
Spyro doesn't give a shit.
Spyro is...
The mass floss.
Oh my god, it's kind of terrifying though.
Yeah, I will beat the game.
And I will record it as a VOD and then when I'm gone sometime I'll post it for you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll see the bots again.
Just not for a while probably.
Funky tonight!
Thank you guys for the fun stream.
I had so much fun.
I hope you enjoyed Astro Bot.
And I will see you guys in the next time we Astro Bot and next stream.
I will be streaming tomorrow.
Not quite sure what yet actually.
But I will stream tomorrow.
I'll have a waiting room up either tonight or in the morning.
And yeah, this game was insanely cute.
And same with Mito.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for playing through it.
It was so much fun.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you.
Otsubito!
I'm gonna go to sleep knowing Mint got 100k plays in our stream.
Shut up!
Otsubito!
Bye bye!
Wait, wait, wait.
Before I say bye bye.
Bye bye!
Wait, I wanna be next to Snake.
That person before that said you needed that area with the 250.
I thought you meant the map.
Or the puzzle.
Finishing the puzzle.
That you would need 250 guys afterwards.
But there's another part of the map that needs 250.
I completely forgot about it.
Oh my god.
You were right.
You were probably like...
She doesn't understand what I mean.
Oh no, Mito, no!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry I misunderstood you.
We'll get it though.
I'll get it when I record.
All good.
No worries.
You silly boy.
All good.
No worries.
We'll get it.
Take care, Mint.
You too!
Thank you guys!
See ya!
Bye bye!